as podcast has bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 131 today
we are gonna talk about the Utah Jazz
have made it past the first round of the
playoffs oh my god how exciting did they
have a chance Josh I don't know the TK
did you told you guys have a chance I
mean come on they they beat OKC and by
the way we've lost 70% of our audience
already they're already leading this her
never talked about sports on the podcast
so I love it so here's the crazy thing
about both the Utah Jazz in the OKC
series first at the end of the year the
Utah Jazz they lose Gordon Hayward and
everybody counts them out everybody says
these guys are gonna be terrible yeah
the Pacers lose Paul George
Paul George goes to OKC and everybody
says the Pacers are gonna be terrible
now and Paul George is gonna lead OKC to
revenge against Golden State and the
complete opposite happens Utah gets
really good and they beat the team that
Paul George went to yeah and then the
Pacers have a total breakout year and
pushed LeBron and the Cavs to Game seven
nobody thought at the beginning of the
year that the Utah Jazz and the Indiana
Pacers will look this impressive in the
NBA Playoffs so maybe the absence of
Gordon Hayward
and Paul George kind of give us a new
idea about how we can succeed in life
get rid of your star player and you'll
go further so like in fact I wrote this
down for a reason because I was i I gave
up on basketball in 1998 Game six of the
finals because my team the Utah Jazz
lost yeah yeah you remember Game six and
in anyway so I just sort of gave up on
basketball for the last two decades and
finally decided to come back but now I I
was watching the series and it was like
oh this is the perfect metaphor for
teamwork you have this team in the Utah
Jazz who probably doesn't have a top 20
player on their team
you could argue I mean you can make some
arguments but most likely they don't
have a top 20 player but they are the
top seven teams in the NBA right
right and and you look at this unit you
realize like oh like like it is true
that the whole is greater than then then
these little parts that you have like
you have some teams that have these
great parts you have a great performer
but a great performer doesn't
necessarily make a great team
yeah very rarely does like one performer
I mean it happens right but when you
have a when you have a whole team that
is supporting each other you usually
have a much better result it makes me
think about what we do with the
minimalist man it's like I'm awesome no
no but seriously it's like you know Josh
is great I'm great but without Sean this
podcast isn't nearly as awesome it's
just two guys rambling in a room exactly
what was a really bad poorly produced
podcast right if it's not for Jess
Williams our social media isn't as
awesome as it is if it isn't for the
people who help edit our our books when
we when we call out for people to edit
those I mean it's every little piece
makes makes a huge difference man
absolutely and so I think that you know
I was I was watching my my daughter
she's four should be five next month she
was playing soccer this this weekend and
she is the russell westbrook of her
soccer team she has all the talent but
not the skill to play with a team and so
like she's clearly the best and the
worst player on the field like the most
athletic has has the most talent but
then also is like i saw a tweet this
morning said what position is it when my
five-year-old picks dandelions on the
soccer field like that's kind of the
thing like she's just not paying
attention it's done her picker right
there's something going on there i think
i think there's a great insight there i
wrote a blog post about this concept
called give me a system not a superstar
and how when we try to build
organizations or create projects is easy
to think that what we need is a
superstar like give me a big-time
money-making venture capitalists give me
the world's greatest CEO and sometimes
when you have a whole lot of talent
concentrated around a single person or a
small group of people it it makes you
lazy because you can compensate for all
of the inefficiencies when you
got a guy like Russell Westbrook who can
will himself to a triple-double who can
just go crazy like he did in Game five
and lead the team back to a massive
combat taking over the game it makes you
kind of say things like yeah maybe we
don't need an offense maybe we don't
need to play defense because you can
afford to get away with it but when
you're a team like the Utah Jazz and you
don't have that star you can't be lazy
so you've got to think about your system
you've got to have a sophisticated
offense to run and I think that's just
an important lesson in life in general
it's easy to rely on your natural talent
on the things that make you great but
it's important to step back and say what
would I do if I didn't have that
what's my rest Russell Westbrook you
know and what would I do if I didn't
have Russell yeah yeah and so let's
listen let's see how we can apply that
because today we're going to talk about
schooling and education and careers as
you college did we introduced TK well
yeah we probably should so you all know
that we don't do interviews so that's
not we're here to do today but
occasionally bring friends on and we
have a new friend with us today to help
us answer some questions that some folks
have we have TK Coleman in the building
ladies and gentlemen TK Coleman TK you
are the education director at a company
called praxis a company that you founded
can you talk a little bit about what you
do at praxis what your company does
absolutely so praxis is a career launch
program where we help aspiring
professionals establish the foundation
upon which they can build their careers
and we orient education around their
goals one of the analogies I like to use
is I like to say we're fitness trainers
for people's career when you go to the
gym your fitness trainer doesn't tell
you all right I want you to run around
that track or I want you to lift some
weights your fitness trainer starts with
you your fitness trainer says why are
you here and maybe your reason is you've
got a wedding coming up and you want to
fit into that suit and look nice maybe
your reason is there's a marathon coming
up and I want to succeed in that
marathon you get to establish what the
goal is and then what the fitness
trainer does is they help create a set
of experiences that show you how to use
the tools in a way that helps you get
where you want to be so every gym has
all of this equipment but each person
who
to the gym uses that equipment in a
customized way in a way that caters to
what it is they're trying to seek after
so my philosophy of education is
essentially this education doesn't begin
with some elitist bureaucratic notion of
what people ought to learn education
begins with what results you the learner
want to create right and the teacher
what the teacher knows becomes relevant
once that information has been obtained
and the teacher uses their knowledge
their experience their resources to help
you create those results so that's
essentially what praxis aims to do
philosophically the way we go about it
is it's a one year program and when
participants come into the program they
spend the first six months doing what we
call our entrepreneurial professional
bootcamp
they learn all sorts of things about you
know digital literacy personal branding
how to how to create value propositions
how to find their voice as writers
communicators all these different types
of things and then in the subsequent six
months they work at a startup and they
learn by doing they learn how to create
value in the marketplace they don't play
with fake money they don't pretend to do
business they deal with real customers
real responsibilities because our
conviction is that if the risk involved
in the learning process are not real
then the rewards of the learning process
are not real so that's in a nutshell
what we do if we want to learn more
about praxis where do they go to check
it out discover as in discover a new
world discover praxis calm that's PR ax
is discover practice I'm Shawn if you
put a link to that in the show notes as
well then people can can check that out
the reason I wanted to bring you in here
today Tek is I've been a fan of your
work for a while I first found out about
you from Steve Patterson's podcast you
so you have some views that you aren't
afraid to talk about with respect to
race and with respect to politics two
things that they will steer away from
today but maybe maybe we'll have you
back on and we can talk about those
those topics as well but forget
minimalize my friendships
[Music]
IIIi was I was really impressed by your
ability to to communicate some thoughts
that are maybe considered against the
grain against the status quo or even
avant-garde thoughts in a way that that
were for me helped me sort of solidify
my position on a few things and I think
you do a really good job through your
blog or through your podcasts and we can
certainly talk about those so I thought
today you were the perfect person
because we had a few questions to dive
into about schooling and education folks
want to want to know what direction in
which they should go you don't think we
should dive into these questions let's
do it all right our first question today
is from Brianna in New York I'm 23 years
old and I've been working at a hotel for
a year now and a few months and I have
found myself incredibly miserable with
what I'm doing I'm a housekeeper I deal
with a lot of stress a lot of pressure
from my department but she's from the
director of my department and it's just
not the right job for me it's just not
the right job for me that I want to
leave but it's difficult for me to find
another job at the cosmologies because
I'm spending so much time at the hotel
that I work out and I'm just absolutely
miserable there and I deal with you know
cleaning with hundred tons of room and
just being very organized is very
difficult because I have a cart net to
put a lot of stuff honey that was for
them they're disorganized from there and
I'm just really very stressed out and
just not happy so with some of the leave
is when I don't have to be there you
know and I've been thinking about going
to college but I kind of put that aside
for a bit because I've just been so
living on everything thinking about when
when I do mess with my life thinking
about you know whether I live in the
future
social life which I don't really have
right now and I just want good advice on
what to do today
we'll lose the job and with my sanity
for sex day until I find another job
alright so the first thing I thought
about well two things I thought about
here Ryan is the first thing I saw this
tweet recently and the tweet was I don't
remember what I wanted to be when I was
growing up but I know it wasn't this
right what a bad feeling man yeah like
and I for me I I remember when someone
asked me I was a little kid must have
been Ella's age I was probably four and
someone asked what do you want to be
when you grow up and I said I want to be
either an alligator or a ninja and I
mean I don't know what Freud would say
about those things but maybe like the
alligator is like I want to have thicker
skin oh and the ninjas I just want to
have a really silent job but but the
other thing that I that I thought about
and I think it's an important question
for Briana's like you know is what
you're doing now what you envisioned
you'd be doing and if not that's okay
you can be in a position right now where
you're paying your bills but what do you
what are you moving toward but the other
thing I want to I just want to
acknowledge her because I hear this
despair in her voice and and she's in
the tornado right now absolutely right
and I've gone through a years of despair
it when a moment when I thought I was
supposed to be at the peak of my life
right when when I was 28 years old I was
a youngest director on our company's 140
year history
I managed 150 retail stores I was living
this life of all sensible success but it
wasn't my version of being successful
right like it was this life of of it was
I would get been given this template and
I fulfilled the template not realizing
that my ladder was leaned against the
wrong building I just continued to climb
that ladder and oh crap now I'm really
high up here and I haven't reached the
place where where I want to go I didn't
feel like I was fostering my creativity
or my relationships or my health I was
working at 80 80 hours a week doing
something that was not I was not
fulfilling I'm I got little bits of
ephemeral pleasure because I had
paychecks that allowed me to
to buy things or finance things that
that gave me these fleeting pleasures
but it wasn't it wasn't the same thing
as happiness or contentment you know
it's funny man I started working in the
corporate world with you solely based on
the salary solely based on those
Commission checks that you were showing
me that you were paying out to your the
people that you were managing and I
remember I just saw this paychecks and
I'm like oh I want to get paychecks like
that like I want to I want to make that
much money and so I got I started you
know selling cell phones very
entry-level position and what happened
is is as I got bigger and bigger
paychecks I started basically putting
myself into more and more debt so I kind
of created this situation where it
sounds like you know maybe maybe Briana
is is in this situation now where you
start a job just thinking alright this
is what's gonna help me get by and then
you accumulate all of this debt you
build a lifestyle around what that job
provides for you and you all of a sudden
realize you're stuck and that it's it's
it feels very impossible to get out
let's talk about like what what is step
number one for Briana here Wow I think
she's only step number one that's okay
the second thing that I that I thought
about here is so she's asking some
questions and that is so important when
we first talk about minimalism and in
simplifying people like what's the first
thing you should do I'm like ask
yourself how might your life be better
with less because that question helps
you understand the why behind the what
the what becomes much easier if you
understand why you're doing what you're
doing I'm holding here in my hand this
short essay from TK Coleman you can find
it on his blog
TK Coleman com and let's just talk about
I won't read the whole thing here but
the title of it is question everything
not just the alternative so I'm just
gonna read the first paragraph and maybe
it'll be a good jump off point for us
because TK wrote here if you want to go
to college and still be accepted by your
family and friends you don't need a good
reason for attending the world will
gladly accept your decision and praise
you for it without the slightest bit of
scrutiny if you want to pursue an
alternative however get ready for the
most intense interrogation of your life
because people will finally begin to
care about all sorts of questions they'd
never dare
to a college student or college
administrator and you go on to talk
about how actually this questioning is
good this sort of self interrogation is
good can we talk about that a little bit
yeah I mean alternatives to the status
quo or things that are that show up in
our lives as disruptions tend to make us
ask questions but the thing to keep in
mind is that those questions can also be
asked of the things that we're currently
doing and some of the most valuable
insights come from identifying those
assumptions that have become invisible
to us because there are a lot of things
that show up as reality they show up as
the way it is when in reality that's
just a point of view that's just a
particular focal setting that can be
challenged and new vistas of
possibilities so to speak can be opened
up as a result of that process of
questioning so as it pertains to this
concern or that this question that we're
addressing one thing I would question is
the the opportunity that is in front of
you what opportunities am i overlooking
not not what opportunities do I need to
seek that are in some other place but
what about the opportunities that are
where I'm currently located so I'll use
an analogy from Disney The Princess and
the Frog you have this frog who is
really a prince that has been cursed and
has taken this hideous ugly form and if
the princess kisses the frog that frog
will turn into a prince now everybody
wants the prince every princess wants a
prince but nobody wants to kiss that
damn frog right so so how do you get the
prince by hoping for a prince by wishing
for a prince by waiting for a prince no
you got to kiss that ugly hideous frog
while it's ugly and hideous right in the
act of kissing that ugly thing is what
transforms it into this beautiful thing
that you've always dreamed up sometimes
we make the mistake of waiting for our
lives to become loveable before we live
it right but you have to love your life
in order for it to become livable my dad
talks a lot about how people make such a
big deal about the law of attraction
right if I focus on the things that I
want maybe I can bring those things into
my
variance but they don't focus on what he
calls the law of recognition which is
practicing my ability to see the
opportunities that are already there so
that I'm not focusing on attracting
things but rather taking advantage of
what is already here with me so my first
step would be to say step back for a
moment and realize that the fastest way
to get where you want to be is by
learning to appreciate where you are and
respect yourself for what you're
currently doing and I don't mean that in
some mystical vague sense like if you
respect yourself and if you're grateful
life will just give you all the
opportunities no but but but really when
you when you live in a state of
appreciation and self-respect you become
more playful you become more creative
you become more intelligent it actually
makes you a better decision maker your
ability to recognize opportunity
improves and what happens is so many
people when they find themselves in jobs
they don't like they despise themselves
for having that job they look at
themselves as losers for working that
job and they kind of have an attitude
that says I'm not gonna be a winner I'm
not gonna be a self-respecting person
until I find that dream job and that
dream job will be the thing that confers
upon me my value but you've got to step
back and you got to say okay wait a
minute this job is like my first
investor okay this job is something that
I chose to do because it can be a means
through which I create something else
that I desire Mike Murdock says that a
champion is someone who's willing to do
what he hates in order to create what he
loves right so this job that I'm working
even though I hate it is a testament to
the fact that I love what I'm creating
so much that I'm willing to do things
that are difficult that other people
wouldn't even be willing to do in order
to create the things that matter most to
me I would contend that it is simply not
possible to find a better opportunity
without respecting yourself as a badass
for doing the thing that you're doing
right now
and by the way Briana's doing a job that
is much-needed Ryan and I stay in a lot
of hotels while we are doing the tour
stops that we've done in the past and
and I'll tell you that I'm appreciative
every single time I show up and there's
an actual clean room for me you know
it's what we were in we were in
Melbourne and we had like accidentally
left our sign on you know there do not
disturb sign on right Ryan I went away
for the day came back and realized like
oh crap like we didn't and we needed
like new towels and stuff so we called
the front desk they sent someone up and
you could tell like she liked cuz we
were in the room like she's in there
straightening everything up and like you
could just tell she was like trying to
like not be in our way trying to be as
you know least offensive or intrusive as
possible and like I just stopped her for
a second I'm like I just want to let you
know something like this whole this
hotel is awesome and like so far we've
had an amazing experience and what
you're doing right now is part of that
experience and without you this whole
thing doesn't happen and like Josh and I
we go way out of our way to show not
just you know that the maid but any
anyone we come into contact with when
we're having a really good experience it
could be a barista
it could be someone working at the
Kinkos where you're getting your copies
made if they're going out of the way to
create a good experience it's possible
for you to be in that experience and be
truly joyous yeah we've all experienced
it's someone who's working you know
these supposedly crappy jobs because
whatever yeah because Instagram doesn't
deem it to be the the nicest job in the
world
guess what that's not real life real
life is we work even even people who do
things that aren't aren't considered you
know the the same type of work that
we've all done at some point you know
I've been a busboy I've washed dishes
I've worked the retail I've done these
these jobs I've shoveled snow those are
the real jobs and it's possible to be
completely joyous within that experience
it doesn't mean you have to do it
forever and I think that's where this
despair comes in is people think what
I'm doing today today and yesterday
equals the future no it doesn't today
equals today and it's possible for you
to be the best version of whatever today
is warts and all and
then figure out how do you where do you
go from here we go so Briana clearly
doesn't want to to be doing this for the
rest of her life we we know that she's
23 years old we support her and not
doing this the rest of her life but but
instead of just running away from this
she has to also have something to run to
is that right in your estimation oh
absolutely I mean there's a Hunger Games
interpretation to what we're saying that
I definitely want to make sure we're
avoiding which is you know be happy with
your lowly job while I sit here on the
towers with my wealth drinking a glass
of wine right where people who live
these elite privileged lifestyles speak
to the people who complain as if your
only problem in life is that you're not
sufficiently grateful right just alone
be grateful for what you have and I will
live this luxurious good life you know
in my ivory tower or whatever it may be
I'm not saying that at all it's it all
begins with self-respect because self
respect makes you a better thinker it
makes you a better opportunity it makes
you a better creator so one step to I
would suggest as in the spirit of the
the stoic Maxim the obstacle is the way
so one of the problems the obstacle she
identified is that she works too much
she wants to find another job but she
doesn't have time right so because she's
spending too many hours at working out
too many hours working so it seems on
the surface as if the best move is to
figure out a way to make less hours so
that you can go find another job but
maybe the obstacle is the way in this
sense maybe you can work more hours I
know that sounds crazy but one exercise
you can do is you can you can ask
yourself how much money do I need to
save in order to be able to survive
three months without my job didn't then
do that exercise for two months and do
that exercise for one month okay and
then work more hours even though you're
already working a lot for however long
you need to work in order to save that
amount then you can leave that job and
you've just bought yourself 30 days 60
days or 90 days depending on how you
execute that plan to go find or create
whatever it is you want to find and
create and at that point you're
completely free you're not worried about
your job and you don't have the stress
of how I'm going to pay my bills in the
mean time so that's one possibility it's
not the only
but that's one possibility yeah let's
get concrete here so you say that you
say that um going to find what you want
to create but it sounds to me right now
like Brianna doesn't know what she wants
to once the crazy she's she's I'm
working here I feel stuck I feel despair
I think part of that despair is because
I don't know where to go from here so
you know it's great that that we see
these successor II posters that say you
know follow your passion but what the
hell does that mean in concrete terms
for someone who is 23 and lost and and
she's actually thinking about maybe I
should just go to college because
college has all the answers I love your
approach TK with with kind of coming up
with this plan cuz I know you're a Tony
Robbins fan like Josh and I are and to
me like that is coming up with that plan
coming up with that goal is a great way
to change your state and and I think
that's really what you're trying to say
am I right on that like she needs to
find a way to change her state to to
look at the the situation she is in a
little bit differently absolutely and I
think something that's important to keep
in mind about the creative process
whether that's making art or finding a
new job is that making improvements or
making progress is much much better than
pursuing perfection right and the number
one enemy of progress is the
idealization of perfection this belief
that you know it's got to be all or
nothing so here's the thing if you are
working a job that you absolutely hate
we all heard the way that she talks
about her job she doesn't like it that's
cool we've all felt that way about
different jobs that means the bar is
probably pretty low for something that
you can like better than that okay now
if you put the pressure on yourself to
go from a job I hate to my dream job
that's just gonna make this whole
process a lot more stressful you're 23
years old you may not even know what
your dream job is for it for a few more
years and try the way it's more
experienced - I mean right your dream
job at 25 is gonna be different from
your dream job at 35 or 55 absolutely so
all you have to do is find something
that you like better than that job or
find something that you hate less than
that job okay um so I I worked a job
that
absolutely hate it and I I worked at a
restaurant and I worked tons of hours
never had enough time to even think or
anything like that
and I made a semi sideways step into a
job that I also didn't like but the cool
thing about the job that I didn't like
was that it ended at 6 o'clock and that
meant I could go home and I could read
books I could work on ideas I could take
walks I could think about what I wanted
to do because my workday ended I was no
longer working until 2:00 in the morning
every day and that became something that
I was able to leverage into the next
step so think in terms of leverage and
levels what's a step I can make that
gives me incremental progress and then I
can use some of the conveniences and
opportunities in that step to sort of
explore an experiment with the next step
yet when it comes to Brianna looking at
the next job I mean the first thing I
have written down for her to do is to
get clear on what her values and beliefs
are because sometimes yes we know we
need to leave a job we know that we
might go into a job that isn't gonna be
our dream job it's gonna be maybe this
next step towards something better but
some people don't even know how to
approach that next step and for me it's
getting clear on on what it is that that
makes Brianna tick and it could even
start with stuff that she hates I mean
is it the fact that she hates not having
time to look for a different job maybe
that should maybe step number two for
Brianna is just finding a job that she
hates just as much but maybe it gives
her the time to focus on some things
that again will will give her that
progress what do you think Millie I
think I think she is looking for an easy
out and I think sometimes college is
that easy out because people think of an
essay as a two to four to five year
break right and so that this so she's
not even looking at what is the next job
what is the next career path she's
looking for an exit ramp and we often
mistake
I think college and going into a
lifetime worth of debt so I mean it's
it's the only thing in the world I think
that we hand the keys of a Lamborghini
over to an 18 year old and say hey good
luck with this there's no insurance on
it and and then and please don't crash
right and then of course
we did we end up going somewhere like we
we end up as a you know a dog-walking
major and and you figured out that like
well wait a minute that I this was just
a detour for me because someone else I
mean that's why I was reading your essay
or earlier TK is so someone else gives
you this template and everyone it says
this is a societal template now and I'm
not saying there's anything inherently
wrong with college I don't know if you
agree or disagree with that but but for
me the there's something inherently
wrong with thinking there is an answer
when there are multiple answers out
there and I think quite often we look at
college as like well that's going to
give me the skills I need to be better
prepared for the workplace yeah I think
that's not necessarily so if Briana
wants to be a brain surgeon then go to
go I mean if that's what she's truly
passionate about and like she has gone
through and really discovered that yes
being a brain surgeon really aligns with
her values and beliefs then go to
college Briana but college I agree with
you Josh it is not an exit ramp it is in
a lot of cases it could be a situation
you know jumping out of the fryer into
the frying pan except when you add debt
to that equation it's like jumping out
of the fryer into a bigger fryer maybe
absolutely I sell two things one about
curiosity the other about college of
regarding curiosity I think following
your curiosity or rather experimenting
with your curiosity is far more
important than finding your passion
right finding your passion that's a hell
of a lot of pressure what in the world
is my passion I now have to reduce the
entirety of my life the totality of my
being to the one thing that I love more
than anything else I mean who knows what
that is right and if you think you know
what that is you're probably wrong right
so you know and then not only that but
if I find my passion and then I announce
it to the world and I justify it and I
defend it what happens if I experiment
with that for three months and now I'm
bored with it now I look like a flake
now I look like a liar now I look like
I'm somebody that's overdramatic that's
just way too much pressure instead of a
god instead of trying to find your
passion just follow your curiosity find
something that seems interesting to you
now and without pressuring yourself to
have all the answers or know that this
is what you're going to want to do in 30
years just investigate your curiosity
without a sense of loss investigate your
curiosity with the
confidence that even if you turn out not
to like it you will discover valuable
things about yourself that will be
transferable to future pursuits that's
the first thing with you guys it's often
my head when we first started the
minimalists comm almost eight years ago
I remember we had friends in the in the
blogging space who late they would start
a new blog every every 30 days and like
just abandon the old one not like
following curiosity be like all of a
sudden I'm they would just dive I'm
really passionate about barefoot running
this month and then I'm really these
real obscure things which is great if
you're following your curiosity and
you're like experimenting with these
different things but people will get
their whole identity wrapped up in this
thing is I'm supposed to be passionate
about paleo barefoot running on
Thursdays and you're like well wait a
minute that's so that is so specific
that that doesn't seem to me like a
passion so much as a curiosity I like
that following the curiosity eventually
allows you to cultivate passions and and
the thing we were talking about earlier
the thing you're passionate about now
you might be passionate about for a
decade but it may not be a lifelong
pursuit either and that's okay and I
think the other thing to cultivate
that's really important is your
willingness to see something through but
also your willingness to walk away if
it's no longer serving a purpose in your
life right you know I no longer play
with GI Joes because they don't serve a
purpose in my life
but they did at one point and I think
our willingness to walk away is the sort
of superpower that we're able to
cultivate that allows us that allows us
to pursue those those curiosities now
exceed okay you're gonna race this one
about about college okay man if Isaac
Morehouse is listening to this right now
he's got to be cringing because it seems
like every time I open my mouth I move
it away from college and school but I'm
coming back to it I promise you but I
got to say something about what you just
said about dreams um one of the things
that I believe the most about pursuing
your dreams is that you not only have to
follow your dreams but you have to let
your dreams follow you one of the most
underestimated things about dreams is
that the very act of pursuing something
that we want is an alchemical process it
transforms us you cannot remain the
person that you are when you're
visualizing a dream when you take action
steps towards its realization so dreams
transform you and when they transform
you
it's it's important to take pauses and
look back on your life and ask yourself
how have I evolve and how can I upgrade
my dreams accordingly one of the great
tragedies and we see it in a city like
LA is you have a lot of people who come
to LA at 18 19 20 to be actors and at 25
26 27 they don't have the passion for it
anymore they don't really love the work
but they're slaves to the dream that was
conceived by a former version of
themselves and they feel like if I go
work in an office if I go work in
corporate America if I start a business
then I'm a sellout because I'm beholden
to the dreams that I had when I was 19 I
fought for these dreams I announced them
I wrote blog saying this is what I'm
going after and I don't want this
anymore does that make me a bad person
forget about that you are an evolving
person you're never going to be the same
now that you've pursued your dream for
three or four or five years you're
someone different than you were when you
didn't know anything about it so don't
just follow your dreams let your dreams
follow you upgrade your dreams to
reflect the person you are always in the
process of becoming um can i what I want
to interject to and make sure make sure
we get to college so Sean I put a link
to a talk that that TK has you still my
idea how you men Oh am i no no no no
totally linking because I forgot
yeah good it works really well here so
absolutely does dreams don't come true
decisions do right amen it's a great
talk and so I think that's it's a good
place to start about taking action as
opposed to just wishing for the thing to
happen but what I love about what TK
just said is he was saying that
sometimes we find ourselves stuck we
find ourselves in a tornado like Breanna
like Breanna has and it's kind of our
own doing and if we stop sometimes this
isn't every single time but sometimes if
we stop to think about why we're in a
situation we're in we've got to look at
the rules that we've created for
ourselves and some like the rule that TK
was just talking about the rule was well
I'm not allowed to be happy unless my 18
year old dream comes true and at 25
years old that hasn't come true yet is
that still gonna be my rule
for being happy Wow so what you're
saying is sometimes we set up the
shittiest rules that we don't even
realize we're playing by like yeah out
of bounds for us is the foul line and in
basketball and you're like wait a minute
that's not an actual rule like I impose
that rule on myself and what I'm saying
is maybe I don't need the rules that
I've create our maybe maybe I've just
how grown some of the rules that I've
created and our willingness to let go of
some of those rules I think some rules
are still important absolutely and some
of those rules aren't shitty some of
them are they serve a great purpose at
that time in our life yes they provided
the appropriate boundaries then but now
those boundaries as we've grown are now
inappropriate I think about having a
four year old should be five this month
and and the boundaries that we have to
put up now they're they're changing you
know since she was two and they'll
continue to change as she gets older and
grows but of course as adults we
continue to grow but in a different way
and so I think the boundaries that we
set up for ourselves sometimes we need
to tear those those boundaries down
otherwise we're we're rotting in our
self-imposed prisons yes I I want to
actually I do I do want to talk to
Briana about some some different ways
she can change her state because I think
it's really important for her to change
her state we've given her one idea about
coming up with a plan to to kind of give
herself a safety net to exit but before
we go before I digress on that let's
let's go back to the college you want to
talk about that yet or you got something
else you want to talk about yeah so man
first of all you you you quoted me
dreams don't come true decisions do let
me give you guys a shout out for that
because I think I've had like a hundred
people follow me because y'all talked
about that follow TK on Twitter at TK
underscore Coleman well TK I want to say
man it's so funny people all the time
they will you know send me emails him
coming out with this book and I give you
a copy of my book and you know do you
mind reading it and giving me a blurb
and usually what I'll say is is like no
I don't have time to read every single
book offered to me you know I'm slow
reader and I get a lot of offers but
what I would love to do is I would love
to help support you by sending out a
tweet or you know something on social
media to promote the book here's the
thing though man is like we could send
people your way all day long but the
reason why they stick around because of
you it's not
the minimalists blurbed you we could
blurb every single person that we know
but if they stick around and read your
stuff TK it's it's for you so thank you
man for doing what you do we will so
thanks for keeping us credible exactly I
appreciate it I appreciate that the
dreams a little plug the dreams don't
come true decisions do that's my talk I
gave it fee con you can check that talk
out with the same title on YouTube yeah
I'll put a link to that in the show
notes yeah yeah and and and you know
that the basic idea there is I I like to
draw an analogy analogy between dreams
and decisions and desire and love you
know desire that's that's the stuff you
long for whereas love is what you're
willing to live for you know desire is
what you care about love is what you're
committed to right and the idea here is
I heard one poet say that love is his
desire raised to a higher power and we
live in a world that that encourages us
to think about what we're passionate
about without also thinking about what
we're willing to prioritize to be true
to our desires without being true to the
honest truth about what we're willing to
commit to when it's all when it's all
laid on the line so for instance there's
an Alan Watts video on YouTube where he
talks about the idea of what would you
do with money were no object and I think
that's an immensely valuable exercise
because you know it's good to sit back
and say hey if everything was free and
there were no costs what would I do then
if I wasn't influenced by scarcity and
sacrifice and I think that's useful but
that only tells us about your desires
right it only tells us about your
passions it doesn't tell us about your
priorities and what you're willing to
commit to I not only want to know what
you would be willing to do if there were
no cost I want to know what you'd be
willing to do if it cost you everything
I don't want that want to know what
you're willing to do if money were no
object but what are you willing to do in
spite of the fact that money is an
object in the world that we live in
right you know and I think it's
important for people to think about both
sides of that and this idea of dreams
don't come true decisions do you know
it's kind of getting at that notion
college that's a great talk by Alan
Watts cool
make sure to find that and put a link to
in the show notes also college yes so
you know the thing you were talking
about is this notion that there is only
one way this is rooted again in an idea
about education that is relatively
modern which is that a bunch of
authority figures or political elites
gather together and decide what
constitutes a good citizen and then we
establish a system of compulsory
education to make everybody study those
things even if those things aren't
relevant to their own goals where we
take the power away from parents and we
take the power away from learners and we
put bureaucrats who don't even have to
bear the consequences of the education
and we put them in charge of deciding
what people will learn what people will
study what it means to be smart and so
forth and so what happens is we end up
with the world where we think about
education in terms of right and wrong
and so we have what I consider to be
these completely meaningless and
arrogant debates about what kind of
education young people should pursue to
me this is silly because we don't have
debates about whether someone should
take a yoga class or a Tai Chi class you
take the class that you want to take
based on what you're interested in we
don't have debates about well should
should adults take courses in meditation
or should adults take courses in piano
it doesn't matter right what do you want
to do are you interested in piano
because if you're not then take the
meditation course or something else that
you're interested in
but but we do something to young people
that we never allow to be done to
ourselves we treat this thing called
learning as if it's about something
other than what you want to create and
what you need to know in order to bring
that forth so I think the idea that
there is a one right way is a very
dangerous idea you know I heard you and
Isaac you have a podcast together called
office hours would you check out
wherever you get your podcasts and I
think that you were talking about how
silly it is because well in the same
thing with this essay we start bringing
up these well I want to go for because
of the social experience like you can
have that without taking on tuition you
can have the social it like if that's
truly the reason you're going to
colleges for the social experience then
just
you move to the college talent you want
to move to and have the social
experiences audit the classes that you
want to take you talk a little bit about
that but about having if you really want
the college experience why you don't
necessarily need the the traditional
college experience well absolutely I
mean there's nothing that stops anyone
from moving to a college town renting an
apartment and attending college parties
and attending college basketball games
attending football games hanging out
with all students college students you
only don't have to be a college to do
and you'll probably have way more fun
you'll probably have a much better time
and make more friends you can go to
parties without worrying about studying
for the finals you can even party during
finals week and in fact in spite of what
someone is probably going to write in
the comments well not at my university
or well there's a technically a rule
that doesn't allow it let's keep it real
for a second you can pretty much go into
any college lecture that you want
provided that it's not a class of only
like five to ten people where you'll
stick out like a sore thumb
and you can sit in that class and you
can listen to the lecture you can learn
about the materials you know with it
without even enrolling to get credit and
by the way you can do that online now
and I mean from Yale and Harvard and a
bunch of other places you just gonna
listen to some lectures you can do that
from your couch absolutely and and I
don't think by the way that the social
experience is the real reason in fact
here is a proposal I would suggest let's
say College said let's say all
University said we're gonna continue
doing things as we have always done them
we'll continue hosting classes will keep
this campus people will enroll blah blah
blah blah the one thing we're going to
change however is we don't give you a
degree at the end of the experience how
many people do you think are going to
continue going the moment you take away
that degree the moment you take away the
thing that says this is what validates
your experience this is what signals to
the adults in your life that you are a
responsible person that we weren't just
feeling oh yeah yeah you're willing to
to in and by the way a lot of employers
are looking for that they are looking
for the the conformity side of things
right like I want you
prove to me that you can conform to so
the reason I would dispute that I would
challenge me I don't think employee
employers look for it conforms I think
it depends on who the employer is right
and what the role is right if you're I'm
going to take a step further they say I
don't think there's a single employer
who looks for conformity okay so so
you're saying in Briana's job they're
not looking for someone who's gonna
conform to the rules and regulations
what she's doing right now I think that
certainly appears to be the case but I
think there's something more fundamental
that we're calling conformity because
our idea of this more fundamental thing
is vague I think what employers want is
a combination of social intelligence and
value creation what everybody in every
relationship once is a partner that's
going to do a really good job at
identifying what they need and then
meeting that need and it just so happens
that if you are intellectually lazy and
you just conform and play the rules
there's a decent probability that you'll
do that right if I'm your buddy and I
say to you well what do you want what do
you want just tell me what you want and
I'll do it there's a decent chance that
I'll kind of make you happy in that way
but I'll probably miss out on some
opportunities to be creative and make
you happy in ways that you probably
couldn't give me instructions for how to
do so so we call that conformity because
that's our only understanding of how to
create value but what employers are
looking for are people who can walk in
understand what the vision is for that
business what the goals are for that
business and then figure out ways to
help realize that goal I have never met
and I never will meet a single employer
who would get angry at a worker if that
worker did the following two things
number one made the business more
profitable as a result of their being
there and number two did it in a way
that was so classy and smooth that they
actually share the credit and made the
person that they work for look good in
the process you can't do that through
conformity and there is no one that
would get upset in that that's
creativity so I think what TK is saying
is that employers they're not looking
for conformity but what I think you're
saying I agree with you Josh is that
there are employers who accept
conformity with within their employees
right maybe maybe like how many
employees that we have were like they
conformed they did exactly what they
were supposed to do but we just always
looked at him like god we wish you would
like really take some stuff in your own
hands and do things a little bit
think for yourself yeah the the the
people who really stood out we're doing
exactly what you were talking about so
when we managed a bunch of retail stores
and managed sales people and operations
people or whoever might be it's the
people like Harding worked with us so
we've got podcast Sean here and he was
one of the best employees at the
corporation and we stole him yeah and
the the thing was like he you know he he
did things that were weren't conforming
but were above it was value creation as
you called it right and and and for us
that was that was not just noteworthy
but it was praiseworthy and he wasn't
well well he wasn't worried about taking
all the credit either because he knew
who was doing it he got the credit that
he he deserved but he was also willing
to go out of his way to create value for
the company wasn't conforming to the
norms he met the norms and so yes
corporations and companies and small
businesses they don't want people who
are going to sabotage the company
obviously and maybe that's what I meant
by conformity is there are some norms
with within which you need to stay right
but that's that's true for driving down
the street as well you have a person
who's who's driving down the median
that's going to be a problem for
everyone right and so I think for for
this exercise what I'm talking about
here whether it's Brianna or we pan out
a little bit we're gonna have people who
are like hey my son or daughter is
thinking about going to college and of
course that is the right thing that's
what you're supposed to do why why isn't
that the thing that they're supposed to
do because the world is changing right i
and and and this is an undeniable fact
we do not live in the world that our
parents grew up in that our grandparents
grew up in so for the sake of argument
I'm going to concede the point even
though I think the point I'm conceding
is debatable but I'm gonna concede the
point that 10 20 30 years ago a degree
was necessary to be a player in the
professional world okay
or at least helpful you're gonna concede
it was at least helpful sure sure we'll
make that concession and I think this is
analogous to saying 15 20 years ago
getting a taxi was the best way to get
around if you were trying to go
somewhere and you couldn't walk or bike
and you didn't have access to the bus
right that that was the way to go 15
years ago you didn't hear me bragging
about uber you heard me taking the taxi
right because that was the option of my
day 15 years ago what uber has done is
it has taken what the taxi provides and
it has reduced the costs it's made it
more convenient more accessible right
there are all these different advantages
that uber has that taxi cabs don't have
even though we still have people that
will fight for the taxi cab right and an
uber represents or just ride-sharing
period because I know someone's
listening who has a problem with the CEO
of uber but let's not limit the concept
of ride-sharing uber there are many
different companies they do it
but what ride-sharing does for us or
what it represents rather is the
changing world in which we live there
are new ways to get around there are new
ways to transport ourselves from one
place to another there's no reason to
for us not to expect that this is also
true of everything else namely education
there are new ways emerging with with
the way technology is providing us with
other options there are new ways for how
we can transport ourselves from one
place to another there are new ways for
how we can launch our careers and I
would say in many ways Isaac Morehouse
uses this metaphor College is like
taking a train or taking a bus it's a
very linear approach to career
development and what we're doing a
practice it's more like taking a rocket
into space we're not trying to move you
forward we're trying to help you
transcend the existing paradigm and play
the professional game at a level that
college isn't even designed to teach
okay this is an important thing that
college doesn't even profess or claim to
teach but one of the challenges is that
as with any alternatives because this is
the nature of the status quo bias when
things are new we question them when
things are familiar and old we just kind
of assume it's the way it is and it's
kind of right or whatever but one of the
challenges of doing something other than
college is that you got to pay a high
social cost now this is something that I
know because I work with the
of young people who choose to opt out of
college there they're enjoying their
lives they're living successfully and
most of them have major challenges from
families or adults in their lives
we're who worry about them and get upset
with them because of this
what kind of objections do you see with
I mean what are the common objections
that the family members see because I
see it all the time
most families want they want the best
for their kids right and so it's not
that that they're they're like
challenging them out of malice or like I
really want to stunt your growth I think
quite often they don't realize it is
stunting so can we talk about that a
little bit yeah I'm gonna make a riskier
claim here
you just said parents want what's best
for their children yes I think at a
certain level that's true but I think
there is some benefit in investigating
that subjecting that to scrutiny here's
something that we all know about parents
they're humans - right parents just like
young people have insecurities just
insecurities about different things one
of the benefits of being an adult is
when you get 30 or 40 you realize that
we have all the same problems it's just
that the toys are different right we
play with different toys we play with
you know automobiles and houses and
fancy titles and jobs and things along
those lines I heard one person say that
adult problems are simply youth problems
left unresolved you know that there are
just few problems and that's it right so
adults are insecure as well
now think about when young people make
what seems to be stupid decisions most
of those stupid decisions are the result
of insecurity yeah at a certain level
young people want what's best but young
people often compromise what is best for
them by prioritizing fitting in
prioritizing you know not making a
ruckus not standing out not being
alienated and parents are subject to the
same temptations so we can't we can't
fool ourselves into thinking that
parents make decisions about their
children's lives from this emotionally
detached state where they experience no
insecurities about what
people are gonna think of them and
they're just doing economic calculations
about cost and benefits for their
children because what their children do
is also a reflection on their
performance as parents yes and you
better believe it if your son Billy I
know you don't have a son named Billy
but if your son Billy I thought if your
son Billy says that I don't want to go
to University of Kansas I want to go do
this apprenticeship thing or I want to
start my own business your your friends
are going to talk with you and you'll be
like hey how's your daughter Katie all
Katie's doing good she's starting
college you know that you know this
August and she's really excited how's
Billy doing oh uh
Billy's doing good he's gonna be
starting a business and stuff like that
okay is he not going to college no no
he's got this entrepreneurship thing
that uh you know that he wants to do and
now here comes all the questions that no
other 18 year olds gonna get well what
kind of entrepreneurship thing but by
the way I think this is so funny every
other week I see some 18 year old on
Facebook and now saying that they got
accepted into college and all you see
are like fifty to a hundred comments of
just congratulations congratulations
congratulations congratulations nobody
nobody gets on there and says well are
you sure that's the right College no one
gets on there and says well what's your
major because you know you know you want
to make sure that you pick the right
major
no one says well what's your purpose for
going to college how are you just going
to fit in or are you how are you gonna
use that degree right no one poses those
questions we just sort of grant them the
assumption that you're going to college
this is a good thing however if you take
the alternative you are going to get
drilled with sophisticated philosophical
questions that most 35 year olds don't
even have the answer to about their own
lives well what happens if you if you
fail I mean it go ask a 35 year old I
don't know what happens to me if I fail
right what happens to you if you fell
well what what if you don't like that
well what if you can't get a job you do
know that all of these same questions
are are real for college students -
right but in even more real in some
cases right more real okay cuz because
you've just gone through four years of
of this system or sometimes longer than
four years you know because idea the
only thing better than a bachelor's
degree is a master's degree and the only
thing better than master's degrees it is
becoming dr. Milburn right
like that that's got to be better and
then God forbid we have a step after
that where it's like extra doctor or
something and and so what happens is now
you have this greater burden on you that
the failure is now even more egregious
or our failure is is it the truth is
what happens when you fail I am going to
fail that that's the only honest answer
to that is I'm going to fail I'm gonna
fail a lot I hope I don't fail so much
that it ruins my life but I hope I fail
my way towards success because tomorrow
success is paved by a whole Road of
yesterday's small failures right yeah
yeah but college is like your your
Russell Westbrook it's the thing that
allows you to not have to think about
those tough questions because you have
something that people are going to
worship and and you can kind of get away
with being a little less critical in
other areas so in college in a way I
apps I absolutely believe that
contemporary views about college you
know borders on the line of religious
but I want to say one more thing about
the parent thing because I don't want to
paint a picture of parents as sinister I
do acknowledge that at a fundamental
level parents do want what's best for
their children
but we also know that since the
sincerity is not a substitute for truth
having good intentions doesn't
necessarily mean that you are giving
good advice
but parents also have insecurities and
they also have pressures now on there's
a million minimal Maxim's here you can
tweeze out and put it into the show so
we do these things called minimal
Maxim's we'll tell you about a letter
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you but
it's making a note for Shawn to write
this [ __ ] down it's all good all right
so here's here's one of the things we
know about failure when a person fails
people tend to look for where we went
wrong right we look for who do we blame
what was the the bad decision that led
to this failure what happened right and
so one of the things that people think
about when they make decisions is not
just the probability of success but what
kind of answer they can give when people
start asking questions should this
project go to hell right so so that that
is a major driver in human behavior now
what happens if someone goes to college
and they're unhappy with their lives by
the way we don't have to treat this like
a hypothetical stop talking to
professor's for two seconds
stop listening to parents argue for
college for two seconds and just go talk
to human beings go randomly walk into a
Starbucks and sword innings anywhere and
you will find thousands of people that
complain a lot that are unhappy that
hate their lives and they have college
degree so this is a reality but no
parent feels like a failure because
their son went and got a degree in
English or anthropology and works at
Starbucks and is unhappy with his life
because you can tell yourself a
narrative that said I did the best I
could I did my job
you can answer all the hard questions if
someone comes to you and says why in the
world is your son unhappy with his life
you can you can step back and say hey
look I raised them well I got him into
college I sent them to a good school you
know it's on him if he's not gonna apply
himself or he's not gonna push himself
that's on him on the other hand it's a
way to abdicate responsibility in a way
where you're saying well I've done what
I can do but but for some reason the
road ends at at you know four years of
college or whatever that that's all I
can do as opposed to like I did all I
can do up until age 14 or 18 or whatever
that might be we have so much faith in
college as the answer that it is the
case that everything prior to college is
oriented around getting kids to college
like that that that that is moat that is
the conception for most parents of what
their main responsibility is I mean yes
I prepare my child for life and so forth
but they make a lot of decisions when
children are very young that are
designed to put them in a position where
they can get into a good college and
then the assumption is that college will
take care of the rest but I would
contend that failure isn't the thing
that people are really afraid of because
they know they can go to college and
still fail what people really fear is
failing and being alone failing and
being blamed for it
and so a lot of people will choose to
take less risk and pursue dreams they
don't even care about because they know
that the cost is low if they fail rather
than just do something they really want
to do because they know if they felt
like that they'll be alone so one quick
example well hold on so is this why
LeBron got all these garbage players on
his team yes yes yes yes so that if he
wins he can say he took you take all the
credit for Cleveland is somehow light it
was
him and four guys from down the street
that I just put on the team yes colleges
LeBron and LeBron is the king of
lowering aspect but but if they lose he
could be like well look I dragged them
as far as I could right I know I know
you're not a LeBron I saw all the points
III got all these good grades it's
everyone else around me it couldn't be
my fault like I have a triple-double it
doesn't matter that that Kevin Love was
an independently established all-star
before he played with me it couldn't be
my fault that he doesn't feel part of
the team it couldn't be my fault for not
utilizing his potential and helping him
feel comfortable you know even though
George Hill played really great before
coming to Cleveland and now he seems to
be mediocre it couldn't be because all I
want to do is run isolation plays where
I kicked the ball out to the open
three-point shooter and I reduce
everyone to Cal Korver no no no I have a
triple-double so that makes me immune
from criticism I should stop because I'm
probably gonna offend more people with
there are four people listening to this
podcast are going nuts over these
basketball and they're really EXO so in
all four of them are loving it right now
there's about a million people who
listen to this this two or three million
a month they listen to this podcast and
and I'm thinking that maybe 17 of them
appreciate the bat I apologize and I
will stop until Utah beats Houston in
this series all right so let's say that
let's say there's a girl that you want
to date you're in love with her and your
mom disapproves your mom says stay away
from sandy she's a bad girl bye-bye I
completely disapprove and you say mom
I'm gonna follow my heart and so you
date sandy and one day you and sandy get
into an argument and you go to your mom
for advice and you say mom you know
sandy and I are in this argument about
this she sees it this way I see it that
way do you think your mom's gonna
respond to that by saying well look look
at it from Sandy's perspective I mean
there's more no no no what she's gonna
say is I told you to stay away from that
girl right I told you to stay away from
that girl this is the cost of doing
things that other people think you
shouldn't do the cost is when you have
struggles people won't have any sympathy
for you III know stories no need for me
to name names but I know stories of
parents who've said to the
children if you opt out of college and
sometimes it's for praxis sometimes it's
to start their own business and do other
things that you get no help from me okay
if you struggle to pay a bill or
whatever it may be you get no help for
me for me you go to college I'll pay now
it's the right of the parents to do
whatever they want to do with their
money so I can't hate on that at the end
of the day you're not obligated to give
your money to another adult if you don't
want to also burn their money right in
front of their child if they want if
they want seems like that approach
though to help someone yeah yeah I mean
so that that's the hard part about doing
unconventional things is it it does have
a greater social cost and if you fail if
you fall on your face people won't
sympathize with you because they will
say well you're experiencing all the
things I warned you about right right on
the other hand if you go to college and
you hate your life but you followed the
rules you did what you were told you you
followed the existing map you can have
all the struggles in the world and
people will listen to you and they will
accept as the explanation for your
struggles that yeah life is hard life is
unfair
you know let's see what we can do to
cope with this and those kinds of things
play a huge role and not only the advice
that parents give to their children but
also on the decisions that that children
make so how do we help someone cope with
that if they got parents telling them
hey we are here for you we're gonna help
you as long as you go to college if you
do anything different than that you've
got nothing from us so how does someone
how does someone uh I guess do you have
any advice on how someone could trust in
themselves a little bit and in taking
that step how can they how can they look
at life and say you know what I don't
need my parents help I can I can totally
try this on my own and I'm willing to
take that risk because the example that
you gave in that situation it would be
very hard for me to not sure go along
with college sure so I believe the
solution is a radical self honesty I'm
pretty non dogmatic about this I don't I
don't think there's anything wrong with
accepting help from your parents I don't
think there's anything wrong with being
25 years old and living in your mom's
basement we always make fun of that guy
right I don't think there's anything
wrong with that you get to decide what
your priorities are in life all right
and you have relationships with people
and if those people want to help you
and you're cool with accepting that help
I don't have a problem with that you
know I don't feel the need to hold
myself as a judge over your life so I
think the solution is to be real with
yourself about what you want take
ownership of your path and don't be a
victim about it so here's what I mean if
if you decide that what's most important
to you is to have the financial
assistance of your parents I say that's
cool I will not despise you I'm not
under the impression that everybody
ought to move out and support themselves
when they're 18 if you've got parents
that can provide for you and you want to
benefit from that so that you can use it
as leverage for other things go for it
however don't be a victim about it
because what comes along with taking
other people's money is playing by their
rules or at least considering their
opinion when it comes to how you're
going to use the money right like my dad
used to tell me you can't expect me to
bail you out financially every time you
fail but I get to have no opinions about
the choices that you make with my money
it's just like in business if I accept
an investor's money I have to consider
some of their opinions about how to run
the business there may be limitations to
that but if you're playing a sport you
have to realize there are rules in place
and I can't create new rules all of a
sudden that that make the game more
advantageous for you and the same is
true in life if someone else is is
creating the game so to speak then you
better be playing by their rules
absolutely and and there are too many
people out there who who fail to
acknowledge trade-offs they make choices
that that involve priority prioritizing
something like security over passion and
then they try to turn it around and play
victim with that I say no no no no if
you're 25 and your mom is paying your
bills you are not a victim if she wants
to tell you what time you should come
home I'm sorry I know you're 25 but
you're living in your mom's house right
okay she gets to decide what the rules
are for her house and if you want that
independence then go pay for your own
and if you don't want to no problem but
don't be a victim about what your
choosing on the other hand if you want
to have independence then you have to
understand that in every context in
every time period freedom has never been
free freedom is not something that
another person can give you freedom is
something that you have to take that
doesn't mean you have to be
disrespectful about it you can disagree
with people without being disrespectful
always taking ownership of my life and
follow my dreams but that doesn't mean I
gotta call you names in order to do so
right if I disagree with my parents that
doesn't mean I have to say well you're
stupid dude I'm gonna live my life no I
can say you know pops I see it
differently but I Love You Man
you're still gonna be my best friend and
I'm never gonna let you disown me
because I'm gonna be over here visiting
you and calling you every day and tell
them that I'll tell you that I love you
hundred times a day but these are my
dreams and if I end up living a life
that I regret you don't have the magical
ability to jump inside of my body and
experience my regrets for me so I got to
do me but you're still my man and if you
think I'm wrong maybe you're correct
just pray for me be patient with me as I
work out my own path in the same way
that you did but I'm not gonna argue
with you I love you too much give me a
hug
you know I'm gonna be rude in the form
of loving you in spite of the fact that
you're trying to argue with me so you
don't have to be disrespectful in order
to disagree but if you want independence
then you've got to take ownership of
your life and you can't just say I want
to do what I want to do but you got to
be willing to take responsibility for
paying the price necessary to do that so
that's how you do it be honest be honest
with yourself do you want independence
do you want the freedom to do what you
want to do and are you willing to pay
the cost for that if so that's the only
way you can be free if not then choose
your path and be honest with yourself
about it no Ryan Ryan I imagine there
are some folks here who are listen to us
right now whose parents will tell them
or there a lot of parents listen to us
who were saying but to tell my kid not
to go to college is irresponsible
that's the irresponsible thing to do is
that not true
you know I would I would just I would
just challenge that and say it's
irresponsible to give your kids only one
option mmm yeah but but I would do
anything to get it is absolutely
irresponsible to give your kids only one
option because that that doesn't prepare
them for reality that's not true with
anything okay
we shouldn't pretend that it magically
becomes true just because we're talking
about the religion of college secondly
it needs to be made clear that there is
nothing cool or creative or praiseworthy
about not choosing the status quo okay
there are a lot of ways you can waste
the way your potential and live
stupidly even if you opt out of college
right so you can opt out of college and
just sit around and watch spongebob
reruns all day that doesn't mean you're
cool right so it's always a compare to
what sort of questions so I I'm not of
the belief that it's automatically some
good praiseworthy thing if you choose
not to do college there there are too
many people that give themselves free
passes for being cool just because I
don't do what my boring dad does yeah
but you don't do anything at all right
like at least your dad does something so
that's that that's the second thing that
the third thing is IIIi would say if as
a parent you genuinely believe it would
be irresponsible of you to do college
here's a soft suggestion I can make I
can say alright let's assume that
college is the right thing let's assume
that it's necessary instead of sending
your child straight from high school to
college after living 17 18 years of you
making most of the major decisions for
them them never providing for themselves
or any of that if you're gonna finance
their college career whatever make a
deal with them and say for one year
before you go to school because I don't
want you to go there and experiment and
fool around and use college as a as a
highly expensive party right let's take
a year and I want you to get a part-time
job so you can have some
responsibilities so that you know what
it's like to work for somebody else so
that you know what it's like to
experience some of those challenges I
want you to pick one or two places that
you want to visit I want you to see the
world and experience something other
than your neighborhood okay and then
we'll sit down and we'll talk at the end
of that let's say six to twelve month
period about what you want to do what I
what I want you to do and we'll go from
there
and even if your child goes to college
after a year of that they will get more
value out of their college experience
because they will have the kind of self
knowledge that can only come from
engaging the marketplace and having some
real responsibilities and seeing the
world and once they go inside that
little bubble the bubble that's not
reflected by anything in the real world
that is a college campus they will be
able to navigate that bubble with a
greater deal of intelligence and nuance
and they'll get more out of their
classes because you learn more about the
ideas you study when you have real world
experience to weigh it against
compromise yeah you learn how to ask
better questions too and I think that's
that's the the real learning experience
not being regurgitated to or or fault
just following this the syllabus the
syllabus can be great it's a plan just
like taking a year off is sort of
creating your own syllabus for a life of
your anti status quo even even if you do
decide that hey maybe that traditional
path is the right path for me because I
want to be a brain surgeon right and in
order to be a brain surgeon
I have to go to college unless you're in
Cuba yeah I would never let a woodland I
would never let anyone touch my brain
who has not been to school to learn how
to touch my breath on an episode of
office hours Isaac and I had a question
once where someone wanted to know what
they should do because their child
really didn't want to go to college and
they really wanted them to go and one of
the things I suggested and this is
something that's useful for parents is
to treat your money like you're an
investor and if your child doesn't wanna
go to college say okay pitch me I get to
do what I want to do with my money if
you want my money and you want my
support sell me on it I want you to take
some time think about why you want to do
what you want to do and give a
presentation to your mother and I your
father and I showing us how you plan on
using the next six to twelve months why
you think that will benefit you and
we'll see we'll see if we're convinced
this is a pretty easy compromise that
actually puts pressure on the child they
now can't use you as an excuse for not
having the guts to do what they want to
do right they now can't say Oh mom dad
you're not supporting me because I want
to do this and you're getting met now
they actually have to think critically
about what they want to do and how
they're going to use it and you you get
to give them fair treatment so I think
that's a soft compromise by the way I
think you should do that for your kids
who want to go to come now listen it's
like a mini episode of shark tank
I'd love to flip that - what what if
because it can it can strengthen the
parents argument what if the parents
also had to give a proposal to the kid
like here are the three options here's
why college is the best option for you
and I'll be great I think I think that
you talk about being a responsible
parent saying here are the options and
here are the pros and the cons to these
three options I'm not just giving you
one option by the way the fourth option
is pick your own option you tell me what
is the best idea of the route you wanted
today the ultimatum of you go to school
or you don't get my help like that is
that's that's terrible that is a
terrible approach I do want to talk I do
you want to talk about Brianna changing
her state okay so how was Brianna gonna
like stop this tornado we've talked
about school and about how she should
you know maybe look at school a little
bit differently and her approach to
college but you know college to me
sounds like like you said it's this exit
ramp for her so what else besides
college how else can she change her
state do you think man I think the the
the first thing I thought of was it was
you know getting clear on what her
values and beliefs are just so she can
kind of get a good compass on where
she's gonna go but the second thing is
and this is to anyone who is finding
themselves in this trouble is dude I
don't think you are a fan of these but
like I love have to do tests and not
just one aptitude test I would love to
sit here and say oh well you know what
Sean we're gonna put a link to the
perfect aptitude test and the shownotes
that's not how it works there are there
are so many online you can just search
for aptitude tests and take different
different tests just to kind of give
give brianna specifically an idea of
what she wants to run towards what do
you think about after two tests men are
they are they completely insane or do
you think like they're a useful tool i
don't think they're completely insane i
think they're a useful tool so long as
they are used in conjunction with
engaging reality I'm not the biggest fan
of using surveys personality tests and
all these sorts of things as a way of
knowing who I am
prior to or independent of getting out
there and experimenting with reality and
a courageous and playful way at the end
of the day you can't know there until
you go there right you can you can wrack
your brain you can you can do a bunch of
exercise and you can say well maybe I
need to do this maybe this is where I
fit but at the end of the day you gotta
give it a try yeah and I think we've
attached so much drama to the decisions
people make that we put all sorts of
pressure on ourselves to come up with
some knockdown argument that we're going
to like what we choose to do before we
choose to do it take that pressure off
you don't know if you're going
like it you don't even need to like it
all you need to do is pursue an
experience that gives you a little bit
more leverage and that gives you the
opportunity for self-discovery that's
all you need absolutely I'll tell you
one way I did that man and this is the
next thing I have on the list is once
Brianna has some ideas of okay maybe
this is maybe I do want to be a brain
surgeon great let's go with a brain
surgeon thing should she go to school
and just start schooling uh taking
classes for being a brain surgeon like I
certainly wouldn't recommend that what I
did when I was in the corporate world
anything that I found appealing any
profession I found that maybe I wanted
to jump to I would seek people out who
were in that profession like one example
is there is a gentleman who runs the
Better Business Bureau he's a CEO the
Better Business Bureau in Dayton and I
reached out to him I'd you know kind of
had some some interactions with him a
little bit here and there with
networking events but I sent him an
email like hey man I really think that I
would like to be a CEO of a nonprofit
organization Better Business Bureau at
the time seemed like a you know maybe
would be a good fit for me
so I sent him an email asking to take
him out to lunch and just kind of talk
about what it was like being the CEO the
Better Business Bureau I found out I
found out pretty quickly I don't want to
be the the CEO of the Better Business
Bureau but through that interaction it
saved me so much I guess headache as if
I were to just all right I'm gonna you
know what I that's a cool position I'm
going to leave my job now and I'm gonna
start pursuing that I mean imagine the
headache I would have caused myself when
I eventually got to the point run like
oh yeah I don't want to do this so with
Brianna like a year commitment to
figuring out if you like yeah no doubt
in half an hour
exactly so so Brianna I mean that's
that's another way she can change her
state too because right now she is stuck
man she is in a tornado and for me the
only way to get out of this to get out
of a tornado the tornado that I was
stuck in it was to change my state
radically I mean that's why I had a
packing party where I packed everything
up and unpacked things as I needed it
just to really again like just help me
to change my state another way that
Brianna can definitely help herself out
is dude she's got to avoid hanging out
with people who don't support her like I
don't know what her I don't know what
her associations like but I'll tell you
like if she does if she isn't associated
with people who were incurred
urging her to explore other
opportunities people who were not
encouraging her to leave her job people
who are not there for her to build her
up she's got she's got to be able to
change that that is to me like one of
the biggest things anyone who who was
experiencing a crazy lifestyle or a
crazy tornado I think and I think
support doesn't mean just like placating
just saying yes it means challenging as
well but challenging in a way that is
building them up as opposed to tearing
them down absolutely she's got to avoid
any like here's the thing man what I was
in a tornado I had developed all these
bad habits that helped pacify myself mmm
while it was in this I would come home
and I would I would do my drugs or I
would sit there and drink a six-pack or
I'd do both and it was like this really
really easy way for me to unwind to let
go from this world that I hated to get
to this world where I felt like okay
like I don't I don't hate living so much
and bad habits were man it just it kind
of kept me stuck it kept that tornado
going it's not something we were saying
to remove the pacifiers because one of
the things that you can you can be
appreciative of where you're at and TK
saying Breanna needs to be appreciative
of this but also you don't necessarily
need to be contented by and I would say
that you don't want to be fully
contented by it and clearly she's not
but but you don't want to be just
comfortable enough that you're not
willing to make a change to whatever the
next best thing is yeah yeah I think the
biggest thing for Breanna here is she
has to come up with a plan and whether
that is reaching out to people and
professions that she is interested in or
taking out to to tests or coming up with
a plan to save money so she can have a
nice exit plan and have a safety net I
think for Breanna here or anyone else
who's in this is experiencing something
like this you've got to come up with a
plan but what's the most important part
of a plan it's taking the action taking
massive action towards bringing that
plan to fruition so Breanna you've got
to find a way to change your state and
you've got to find a way to take massive
action I know I'm totally ripping both
those things off from Tony Robbins but
uh but it can artists yeah man
absolutely absolutely you know III would
say too there is nothing quite like
ringing up your creative energy from the
from the pressing urgencies and
emergencies that that make it seem like
it's impossible to make a positive shift
and I I know this might sound like very
unromantic unsexy unglamorous advice but
even if you can make a sideways step
into a different hotel right like I I
heard a comment in there about
management so I'm not exactly sure what
the issue is but just because you work
in a hotel doesn't mean you work at a
hotel that's the easiest and most
enjoyable place to work at okay and just
because you go to a different hotel
doesn't mean you're committing to
working in hotels for the rest of your
life but if you already have experience
and connections in that industry it
could be the path of least resistance to
go to a different hotel and that's an
option for you
and perhaps work in an environment
that's less stressful and just by being
in an environment that's less stressful
you might free up some energy to think
about what else you want to do and you
can have a little bit more time to
approach that process patiently so to
talk about Tony Robbins one of the
things he says is most self-help and
motivational speakers start with
changing your thoughts right they start
with like adjust your attitude and think
more positively and constructively but
he starts with the body and the
environment because if you make changes
in your physiology and you make changes
in your environment that can more
readily facilitate the mental changes as
well so I think one of the easiest ways
to you know create a different mental
state is to find a sideways step you can
make that puts you in a different
environment where you got different
influences and demands that sounds like
such a I don't want to say an easy
approach but a manageable approach
meaning Briana could pick one thing
maybe it's her time maybe because she
mentioned that she doesn't have time to
look for another job so maybe she just
starts there and says I need to take a
sideways step just so I can have more
time to think about what the hell I want
to move to next take those appetit yeah
absolutely right take time yeah exactly
so no I love that man because often like
you said earlier we we kind of get this
idea of what perfect is and and how we
need to obtain perfect and if that's our
goal
it's it's
gonna be very it's it's gonna be very
hard to go from like in Briana's
situation she's in the tornado it's not
perfect
she hates where she's at when she leaves
this role it's she's not stepping into
this next perfect situation right Yeah
right well Briana I'd love to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
it was Ryan's and my story about walking
away from careers that we hated we
didn't just like quit our jobs and start
a blog and everything worked out great
there was a lot of pain and heartache
and there were certainly a valley there
that when and there were a lot of small
changes and iterations that we had to
make in our own lives and especially in
changing our habits and I think you'll
particularly find valuable the eighth
chapter which is about changing some of
those habits so it's called everything
that remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever written of our three books
actually my favorite thing we've ever
created Sean if you could reach out to
her Center the the audio book or if you
want the book book or ebook we be happy
to send you those as well our next
question is from Daniel in Pennsylvania
I'm a army vet we went through a
one-year divorce that led me down the
dark path of drinking and overeating and
online shopping almost getting a high
like like feeling when when I won the
bid on eBay
before I knew I had a room full of all
this stuff with no purpose that was a
huge point in my life and after a few
months of the cluttering and eating
healthy I finally feel like I got my
life back in order however I'm about to
start college at my GI Bill so I was
wondering if there was any tips or
tricks about organized organizing myself
in college and just you know college in
general just any any any help from you
guys would be great
so someone has chose to go to college
yes I think I think chosen is the past
participle of choose I love how you guys
are you guys actually the first thing
that I thought when I when I heard this
is congratulations you found your valley
that I wrote that down here because I
there we all have these inciting
incidents and for Daniel was like
getting out of the army and then having
this this one year drawn-out divorce but
then after that it produced you know
what was the aftermath of this crash it
was drinking it was not reading I
actually liked that he he could tell you
not reading is not something people
would usually list as part of their
valley right but like for me that that I
I was just impressed you're like my life
was shitty because I wasn't reading as
much as I wanted to like that shows me
actually some of your priorities are in
a really good place here and he talked
about getting the ebay high the online
shopping and and yeah it's true that
that you do get this dopamine rush but
that high does not last far past the
checkout line right and and we all ride
an iron against consumption we all need
to have some stuff we're all wearing
clothes right now except for Ryan he's
just wearing a loincloth as we're
recording this it was very unreal
minimalist and and you've got this
this desire to continue to consume
though because we feel this this oh that
felt good let me and it were chasing the
dragon right it's it's the same thing
you do with drinking you do it with
shopping it's a different type of
consumption and GI Bill that's free
money for college and so he has some
free money here to play with but
everything that's free isn't necessarily
free right because we have to consider
other resources you're giving up your
time your attention you're giving up
portion of your life to go to this and
so yes first thing I'll say is go back
and listen to the the last question we
talked a lot about college there but how
do we how do we accept the premise that
he's decided to to go to college and how
does he make this a meaningful college
experience yeah so I mean that could be
how does he make a meaningful college
experience while he's there how can you
go about picking the right major I mean
do we need to talk about his approach to
go into college at all or are we worse
maybe maybe we say okay well it and this
would be useful for people who are
already in college because just because
you're there doesn't mean you have to
stay either
Shareen that's the other thing to think
about we we have these sunk costs as
well have already put in two years right
I've already put in I already have 20
credit hours and $40,000 worth of debt
right so of course I need to get another
120,000 dollars worth of debt and of
course I need to get finished this out
because I need that piece of paper and
and the question is is that true
right and and I don't know I I mean if
Daniel were here in the room I would
have some more questions for him yeah
yeah no I totally agree because even
though yeah he does have this
opportunity to go to college for free
the question is what is he gonna do with
that piece of paper once he has it
because if it's if it's a liberal arts
degree you know there are only so many
things he can do with that right or that
that degree is going to be specifically
geared towards how does he choose how
does he choose what major he's gonna go
into cuz I think that's the first step
right like he's decided I got this free
money I'm gonna go to college right but
if I what if I said I hear Ryan here's
30 thousand you thirty thousand dollars
to go to clown school for the next 12
months
I mean I probably would go because I
think clowning is cool but but I
understand what you say no I understand
exactly what you're saying man like it
though if you give me $30,000 to being
it here here's $3,000 you can get your
associates in accounting like yeah I
would not take that for free just
because you gave it to me right because
that's not something that is going to
work so there is is is he pigeon-holed
is daniel pigeon-holed into going to
college with this GI bill well no you
can't force someone to go to college but
is that is this is this the government
playing the most sympathize with them if
so is this is this mom or dad who's
looking at Daniel and saying we'll help
you as long as you go to college I mean
is that kind of the I don't I guess I'm
a little ignorant on how the old GI Bill
thing yeah yeah so it's it's he's an
army vet and and part of to sort of as
compensation partial compensation for a
service they will give you money toward
college the same way that are the
corporation that we work for gave you
certainly have money to go to college
yeah you know it's funny I actually I
started going to college because the
corporation Josh and I worked at they
get they paid for it and I was like I'd
be stupid not to go to school and when I
find myself what I found myself doing
was working 60 70 sometimes 80 hours a
week and going to school and it was it
was not a sustainable schedule and when
it was over I was so happy but but you
know to your point I don't do [ __ ] with
that degree now yeah and I did it just
because you're supposed to and well yeah
and it was paid for well and you were
encouraged to write so I mean everything
sometimes the TK's not in his head here
like yeah everyone encourages people to
go to college and in fact the the myth
is much more powerful than that a really
powerful myth is one that you don't even
have to teach that the curriculum is
invisible it's built into the the very
expectations the very structures of our
society it's the default it's not even
questioned it's not even thought about
it's not even looked at as a decision
it's just what you do so people aren't
encouraged to go to college they know by
the time they're 12 that that is what
they're going to do
because that is how life is oriented for
them so it's more powerful than just
being told that's what they ought to do
yeah so what do we do for Daniel here
he's an army vet he has found his Valley
now I say Valley there are other valleys
out there and there are deeper valleys
you know you could be on heroin you you
you you can yeah it could always be
worse you could be dead yeah but
hopefully this is this is sort of the
nadir for you and and now now the
question is what is the appropriate peak
for you maybe it's college and college
by the way the college experience is
certainly better than the sitting at
home drinking online shopping and not
reading we can we can agree that just
because there's one peak over here
doesn't mean it's the the highest peak
on the landscape so what is the
appropriate peak for for Daniel here and
what questions would you be asking him
right now if you were in the room mm-hmm
so first for those who are listening
that might be considering going to
college or for those who are considering
the sunk cost that you referenced a
minute ago it's important to make the
distinction between transaction cost and
opportunity costs right transaction cost
refers to what we might call price tag
costs right what our receipts indicate
after we're done with the experience the
amount of money I spend on gas the price
of the movie ticket and the popcorn and
the candy that I buy but that's just one
kind of costs but since it's the most
visible the most obvious that's the one
we pay attention to and typically when
we say something is free we mean there
is an absence of transaction costs or or
rather more accurately I'm not the one
that's paying the transaction cost but
there's also opportunity costs and
opportunity costs refers to the value of
the best alternative that you have to
forego in order to do what you want to
do so if I say hey you guys want to come
to the movies with me this Saturday
night I'm paying that means and I'm
picking you up no transaction cost for
you guys
however there is an opportunity cost
you've got to give up whatever you were
going to do or could have been doing
with that Saturday night now obviously
going to the movies with me that's as
good as it gets right but but but the
question you have to ask yourself is
what are my opportunity costs nothing is
free if you're gonna give up 1 2 3 4
years of your life you got to ask
yourself not just is it free financially
but is this the best thing that I could
be doing with my time is this the most
leverage that I can gain
my time and that leads us to a more
fundamental question because ultimately
I believe how you create a meaningful
experience the fundamentals are the same
doesn't matter if it's college attending
a party going on a date the way you
create a meaningful experience begins
with a single question and that is why
am I here why am I doing this right you
don't go to a gym to get in shape in
general why do you want to get in shape
why are you going to the gym what do you
want to get you know and that's the
question I would start with and that's
more fundamental than what I should
major in you know or how many credits I
should take why are you going to college
and you can't let your answer be because
someone else is paying for it that's not
a good reason to do anything the the
last thing I'll say on this is whatever
you do if you're gonna go to college
please please please don't let I went to
college and I got my degree in ABC XYZ
be the most interesting thing about you
because if it is you're gone you're gone
that that has to be less interesting
than how you are using the knowledge and
experience you gained along the way
I said that was the last thing but I
lied here's the last thing abandoned the
permission-based mindset abandoned the
preparation mindset that says life works
in the following fashion
I spend a bunch of time preparing myself
for the real world and then once I'm
sufficiently prepared I get a degree or
I take enough classes then I'll go out
there and I will create value No you
learn how to create value by creating
value learning according to Chalmers
Brothers is the process of doing what
you don't know how to do while you don't
know how to do it not after you learn
how to do it it's doing what you don't
know how to do at the same time as not
knowing how to do it that's how you
learn to raise the child that's how you
learn to build a business that's how you
learn everything that you learn in life
and so if you're going to go to college
once you've identified your why what is
the thing you want to create what's the
lifestyle you want to develop start
investing in that right now in terms of
creative action whether that's starting
a podcast starting a blog starting a
small side business doesn't matter if
you fail what matters is that you're
starting that you're experimenting that
you're putting yourself out there I
totally agree and I think the best
takeaway for me from from those three
points men are it's the one about if
you're
to college just because it's paid for
that's the worst reason to go to college
yeah so so Daniel if that's the reason
why you're going to college I'm not
saying that you shouldn't but but ask
that question why are you at college
there has to be more than just well I'm
getting a paid for so I'm here you can
factor them going through the motions
yeah yeah I think I think that if that's
one it should be one of the factors like
what is this thing called what are the
other costs you know we're talking about
the opportunity cost the price tag the
transactional cost isn't the only cost
we always talk about that with our
material possessions like there's the
cost of storing the thing the space the
thing takes up cleaning the thing
worrying about the thing taking care of
the thing watering the thing whatever it
is they're all these other costs and
it's way beyond oh yeah but the
government is gonna pay for it I'd be
dumb not to do it we got to go beyond
that so so TK what are you when you work
with people who are in in Daniel
situation and you just talked about some
of the and creative creative endeavors
to to embark on what what are some of
the real world practical applications
there that someone can do you know
because to me I always say creating is
is creating is far more important far
more valuable far more meaningful than
than consuming but in creating could be
anything it can be beginning to write
that book you want it to write
creating can be you know singing a song
it can be it can be this whole number of
things but what is something that's
going to be this is gonna put Daniel
down a a meaningful path now what are
some steps that he can take so start
with identifying something that you're
curious about secondly identify some
problems you can solve for real people
by exploiting that curiosity and three
find some real people and pitch them on
the opportunity to solve their problems
or without even asking for permission
figure out a way to try to solve their
problem and instead of saying can I do
this say hey here's something that I did
so for instance I have a participant who
is interested in photography right and
and initially started out saying I want
to study this I want to learn this and
the approach was I'm gonna take a bunch
of classes and I'm gonna get good at
this and I said how about you start with
people who don't have nice photos okay
there are plenty of real human
beings out there many of whom you know
who don't have a good looking headshot
and go up to them and say hey I'm trying
to get some experience I'm trying to
experiment with different ways of taking
pictures I'm trying to build my
portfolio what do you think if I took
family photos of you or what do you
think if I you know took headshots and
my initial suggestion was come up with
like a cheap price that you wouldn't be
mad at mad about you know asking for you
know maybe like 25 bucks 50 bucks
something like that and if they say no
be willing to do it for free anyway
because at the end of the day you're
getting the experience you don't have
like the alternative and that was a
completely different mindset from I'm
gonna buckle down and for two years I'm
gonna study photography like no start
right now with whatever skill you have
even if that means you're gonna make
mistakes and solve problems with that
skill or solve problems with that
interest for real people you can always
do that in every stage
what you're talking about right now is
entrepreneurial entrepreneurship and I'm
thinking of this essay I printed off
from from Seth Godin here it's a really
short one entrepreneur entrepreneurship
is not a job and and here's what he said
he said you don't apply you don't get a
salary no one picks you so so think
about this it the person you're talking
about who wanted to be the photographer
they didn't wait I'm just gonna wait
around to someone picks me I'll I'll go
study and I'll put up a website and
hopefully someone will come pick me no
no an entrepreneur you don't apply you
don't get a salary no one picks you
bragging about how much money you've
raised or what your valuation is is a
form of job thinking entrepreneurship is
a chance to trade a solution to someone
who has a problem that needs solving
solve more problems solve bigger
problems solve problems more widely and
you are an entrepreneur it's tempting to
industrialize this work to make it
something with rules and bosses and
processes but that's not the heart of an
entrepreneur the work is to solve
problems in a way that you're proud of
and I think that last part is is also
important so we're talking about what
you're proud of well yeah the question
that Ryan asked before and we always ask
is what are your values identifying what
your values are because that's going to
be something that that you're
you can go back and listen to episode 69
our values episode and we identify these
different types of values your
foundational values versus your core
values versus minor values versus
imaginary values we with that that's the
big one we all get stuck on right like a
title a job title it was an imaginary
value right and identifying what your
values are because if you know what your
values are then you can start solving
problems in a way that aligns with your
values and helps other people and that's
the way that you're gonna create a
business it's where you're gonna create
a meaningful life that's the way that
you're going in by the way it doesn't
mean you're creating your own business
but if you're working for someone else
what are you doing you're helping that
company that other person the small
business whoever maybe you're helping
them solve problems as well yeah yeah
you could you can reverse engineer your
understanding of what your values are
too by simply observing your behavior
and working backwards to identify what
what underlies your a tendency to do
certain things even when you aren't
being incentivized by money what what
are the things you're always consistent
at what are the things you never flake
on you know economists call this
revealed preference versus stated
preference there's a huge gap between
those two things because for starters
our stated preference don't have any
cost we can say what we desire what we
love what we value for free there's no
risk associated with it right call those
lip service priority yeah yeah my health
is my priority I haven't been in the gym
in four months and I eat like crab or my
relationships are priority but I'm
working 80 hours a week and I forsake my
wife and my parents and the people
closest to me or I say creativity for me
it was always writing was my priority I
am really really passionate about
writing but I was just an aspiring
writer I aspired every damn day of my
life but didn't put any words on paper
until I got serious about making it a
true priority absolutely and and your
behavior showcases your revealed
preferences what do you actually do once
we introduce scarcity and sacrifice back
into the equation that tells me
something significant about you and
here's the crazy thing so you take the
example of the person you mentioned who
you know says I love family but they
work 80 hours a week right
I don't think the solution to that is
necessarily to say hey quit quit quit
being a hypocrite and work for 40 hours
a week and go spend more time with your
family no no it's to say hey man maybe
we should take a look at the fact that
you spend 80 hours a week working and on
the fact that that's what's most
important to you because as long as
you're lying to yourself about how much
you love work as long as you're feeling
guilty about the fact that you enjoy
being at your job more than you enjoy
being around your family you're going to
go about this in the least productive
way but it's interesting because we
demonize working in a way like because
we don't demonize the other things where
you never have a guy where you're like
you know what you just spend too much
time with your family yeah it is it's
not something that and I think the same
is true with college right we don't tell
someone like you know what you are just
spending too much time at college as a
19 year old and it may be better served
doing XYZ like it's taboo to say that
the truth is to let's the step back and
be honest about what the circumstances
are what you the the behaviors the
revealed preferences are in our own
lives yeah and when you're honest with
that it actually paves the way for you
to find a way to pursue it that's more
consistent that's more congruent that's
more compatible with your other
interests you you are never better off
by lying to yourself because lying to
yourself divorces you from reality and
it makes you an inferior critical
thinker but when you tell yourself the
truth even if that truth seems
politically incorrect at first even if
it seems shameful at first you now have
the advantage you now can pursue it in a
way that's characterized by self
ownership and everything is better that
way you know every family is different
every lifestyle is different you know
every spouse doesn't get annoyed and
angry when they have someone in their
lives who works really hard there are
ways to do this there is no one way to
be married no one way to approach your
work life yeah yeah yeah all right so
let's say it's so daniel has committed
to go into school what and I'd be
interested to hear your thoughts on this
DK so how does someone create a
meaningful college experience what do
you think of when you think about that
because I know you're like it's not that
you're against college but you do talk a
lot of
alternatives to college but but someone
does want to go to college how do they
make this a meaningful experience so
what I am against is being on autopilot
with your life what I am against is
doing anything in a dogmatic way that
that that omits the importance of
thinking critically clearly and
creatively about what it is you want you
have to start with the results you want
to create right and if you're not
starting with that then you're you're
pursuing a purposeless aim you're driven
by maybe fitting in or or doing what's
comfortable so I would say don't hide
behind college don't use college as a
place to hide and it's it's it's not
some unfair attack on college to point
out the reality that many young people
do exactly this precisely because
college is about the only thing you can
do where you can go disappear for four
years not do not be productive you can
party you can clown around you can be
average like literally according to
college's definition of average you can
just like get C's and float by I've done
these things okay
many of us have done these things and if
we're not debating we'll admit that
we've done these things okay you can go
to college you can get C's you can just
hang out you can be mediocre but because
you're in the right place during doing
the right things
you'll get praise it's Russell Westbrook
again right so don't hide behind that
don't use College as a place to buy
yourself time don't go because it's like
putting life on pause for four years if
you're going to go if you're going to go
anywhere or do anything go with a
deliberate aim in mind and don't give
yourself permission to take a single
action step in that direction
until you can answer the question why am
I doing this yeah and I think I think if
you are deciding that college is the
right route for me for whatever reason
then the reason that you should go to
college if you're already going is
you're going to get something out of it
right and so whether you're you're just
showing up to a lecture to attend the
lecture and you're not going to the
college and just showing up you want to
get something out of that because you're
being forced to go a little extra quite
often we're just like well I'm being
forced to attendance is is enough but no
attendance isn't enough if you're just
attending for four years you're not
getting what you could
out of this experience right and I agree
it's not about the social experience
it's about what what am I going to learn
what skills am I going to develop while
I am here now we can go and look at the
stats and realize that not a lot of
skills are necessarily acquired during
this four year experience but they could
be they could be so I'll give a second
thing because I was a little bit more
abstract with my prior answer but
something that's practical and we we
reinforced this a lot at practice is
that learning doesn't count if you're
not combining it with some form of
creative creative action right so one of
the most important principles you can
learn about learning is the value of
learning out loud right documenting your
journey of going from I don't know what
the hell I'm doing to I am now a master
of this particular thing what a lot of
people miss out on is the opportunity
for professional branding and and
professional skill and and professional
opportunity that would come from
advertising in a non obnoxious way the
things they're studying so what most
people do for instance at a job
interview someone says hey what's the
positive quality value and a person says
well I'm a fast learner and then the
interviewer says well give me an example
of that and what do people do they tell
you something that they know right they
tell you something that they've already
mastered but that isn't but telling me
what you know doesn't tell me anything
about what you look like and act like
while you are in the process of learning
okay and the most valuable thing for
people that have to work with you is
knowing what you're like when you don't
know what you're doing and you're in the
process of figuring it out but most
people never showcase that because they
hide what they're doing from the world
until they feel confident that they know
what they're doing right and so one of
the best things you can do is if you're
educating yourself you're taking a class
is to learn out loud write a blog post
that says hey I'm TK Coleman I know
nothing about astrophysics but I watch
this Neil deGrasse Tyson video on
YouTube the other day and it really
sparked some curiosity so I never paid
attention to physics class in high
school but I'm gonna start teaching
myself to basic so I ordered this second
grade physics book from Amazon and this
is what I'm gonna learn every single
week I'm gonna teach myself a couple of
new concepts
and I'll document it here on the blog at
the end of three years when I'm able to
talk intelligently or semi intelligently
about physics
I'll have way more respect way more
notoriety way more opportunity than the
person that hid themselves in a basement
while they became the physics master and
then they rear their head once they
think they know what they're talking
about
and they find out that no one really
cares about you man like where have you
been like people respect that they
respect the creations as well so whether
it's starting a blog or writing a book
about it or podcast or whatever they
respect the fact that you've documented
some way and by the way that's gonna
make you stand out what can you imagine
people we used to hire if they would be
like well yes I've been blogging about
Telecom for the last three years and
about how I've learned to become a
better salesman in the process all right
boom hired you're hired yeah not just a
branding thing you actually get more out
of your learning and you have to do that
no that's it's it's a great concept man
like just thinking about yes like you're
going to school to be a brain surgeon
and you're hanging out with brain
surgeons while you're going to school
and you're going to meet up groups of
brain surgeons like you're immersing
yourself as much as you can outside of
school to to help reiterate these things
that you're learning I love I love that
it's funny because when I went to school
I didn't even realize I was doing that
with getting my you know business
management degree while I was a business
manager but but no that's it's a great
approachment you know the one thing that
I really want to when I was thinking
about Daniels question or the one thing
that I want to just make Daniel aware of
and anyone else out there who is facing
this question of like how do I make
college a great experience I think it's
really important to know that there's
always going to be a better option like
the worst the worst I can see are the
worst things I see with college students
because I would hate to feel this way if
I was in the middle of my degree two
years into it and I'm like oh man I've
been going for business management but
that brain surgeon degree looks much
better and maybe I would enjoy that more
and if that person was able to switch
the brain surgery that there would
probably be something else that that
would look appealing to them eventually
I guess this is my way of telling Daniel
is is whatever you do decide to do
with College commit to it and understand
that there are there are going to be
these valleys but they're also going to
be the peaks and I think what you were
saying about just kind of documenting it
the whole time and being engaged as much
as possible with that that profession or
whatever it is that that Daniels gonna
go and get some schooling for like that
is going to help him to stay focus and
to help him stay more consistent
throughout this this this experience for
him but well then how do we how do we on
the the commitment part because I agree
with that to a great extent the
commitment is important nothing nothing
is finished if we're not willing to
commit right however there will be times
were realized we're taking the wrong
path absolutely and we need to be
willing to to not just stick to it
because we've decided to commit to that
thing if it is the wrong path oh crap
I've climbed too far up the corporate
ladder for me to jump down now and so
I'm just gonna keep climbing I guess and
so we do need to be able to make a
distinction between commitment and the
willingness to walk away when it no
longer serves a purpose
totally agreement like we yeah we
absolutely have to be prepared to walk
away from anything yeah and for me it
and this might be different for utk but
for me it's when there are certain paths
I go down and I realize like oh like
this is not only this is is a net
negative meaning that you know all the
inks and the valleys that I go through
the peaks that I get out of it it's just
it's not worth all these valleys but the
other thing too is if it doesn't align
with those values if it doesn't align
with my beliefs like that is for me that
is when that bifurcation becomes very
clear and I have to make a decision what
do you think it's you can yeah so this
is interesting I think I personally
think you can be as non-committal as you
want to be as long as you are good at
establishing expectations and
maintaining frame let me give an example
let's say that's a great that's a great
sorry that's a great maximum showing I'm
going for the maximum record what's the
triple double version of a Mac no but
you've already hit it you've already
said the bargain I love the Russell
Westbrook of the minimalist podcast
I'm going for the triple bevel here I
got nine assists I need one more expound
on that man it's great dude yeah so
let's say I owe you 200 bucks
okay and one day I come up to you and I
say hey man I just wanted to give you
this $100 here and I give you that 100
bucks I owe you 200 how do you feel I
feel like all right thanks for paying me
half the money back yeah what am I gonna
get the other half okay so it sounds
like you feel a little bit confused yes
definitely and borderline annoyed yeah
yeah yeah okay that's fair
all right let's change it up now okay
let's say I don't owe you anything
and I come up to you and I say hey man
um I really appreciate you guys having
me on the minimalist the other day and
uh you guys have had a positive impact
on my life and I just wanted to share a
little bit of appreciation brother
here's $25 let's not argue about it just
take the money I want to show you some
love how do you how do you feel now yeah
sure I would say I'd say thanks man
thanks for the 25 bucks yeah yeah okay
all right so in the first scenario I
gave you $100 and you were unhappy with
me right in the second scenario I only
gave you 25 and I'm the man in your eyes
right
so it's not how much you give or what
you do it's about the framework of
expectations that I'm operating in right
in the first scenario there was an
expectation that I would give 200 so
when I gave you a lot it still came up
short
in the second scenario you didn't have
any expectations and when I gave you a
little it came up looking long so when
it comes to commitments I think where
most people go wrong is they feel the
need to commit to something other than
their curiosity and they say things like
for the next five years I'm gonna do
this it's kind of like what you talked
about the paleo guy I I now brand myself
as the paleo guy and for the rest of my
life my religion is going to be this
thing I mean people don't explicitly say
that but when they leave it so vague so
undefined that's what it feels like
right um
if I say something like I'm gonna start
a new podcast and it's gonna be about
this well now you kind of expect it to
be for the rest of my life
and when I stopped what do you what do
you do you say well what happened to
that podcast yeah but but we don't get
it wrong yeah but we don't do this with
TV shows because TV shows know how to
control the frame
they say this is season one and there
are ten episodes so when we stop doing
them
don't ask any questions the season is
over and we let you know at the last
episode this is the finale it's over
right so it's all about controlling that
frame now when we talk about things like
taking on a new task or learning
something I think we have this default
where we feel like the first response to
a curiosity ought to be to sign up from
support some course or make a commitment
and if we're not doing that we're not
taking our curiosity seriously and
that's part of the skooled mindset I'll
give you an example of this there was a
guy who asked Isaac and I if he should
take a tight low pass course and if I
remember the details correctly he said
it cost about $200 and he was wondering
if he should he's nervous about spending
the money should he make the commitment
and my advice to him was go on youtube
pull up one of Tai Lopez's free videos
okay watch like an hour's worth of his
free videos and then ask yourself am I
tired of this guy or do I want more
right and then you'll have your answer
right because if you're tired of them
from one hour of free stuff then you're
not gonna want to pay the guy $200 or
that's gonna only end up bad on the
other hand if you say I want more if he
says something that moves you and
changes your life doesn't matter what
anybody else thinks watch another one
you know take that process a little bit
further and you'll know organically by
experimenting with it that this is
something you do or don't want and so
because we have this default that says
the first response to my curiosity is to
make a long-term commitment we overlook
all of the free simple playful least
resistant ways to engage our curiosities
so I would caution against this idea
that you know whatever it is you do
commit to it I would say control the
frame say you know what for the next two
weeks I'm gonna try this out dip your
toe in the water dip your toe in the
water yeah and no matter what don't sign
up for a tie Lopez course I just want to
make a point about the commitment
because what I'm saying about commitment
is this man is that if
annual has done the work he has gone
through the last question with Brianna
he has flirted around he's flirted
around with you know talking to other
people in a profession with brain
surgeons I'm just sticking with that
because that's what we've been doing the
whole show and he's like yes like this
is something that I have I have tinkered
around with I've engaged with I find it
entertaining I find it engaging I want
more I want more of this so now I think
the commitment part comes in for when it
gets tough so he goes down this path of
being a brain surgeon and then he gets
his first year residency and he's like
man this is really really hard I think
that's I mean to me that's where the
commitment comes in it's after you've
done the pre-work after you've done as
much as you can to to choose a path for
yourself committing to that it's like
marriage
I mean committing to that path you
you've in you know college is a
temporary marriage I guess but but
that's I guess it's what I'm really
trying to say about commit don't confuse
excitement with passion and I think
while someone that gets excited about a
nice idea and all of a sudden the
actions have to put in the work there's
drudgery involved and you have to be
willing to Drudge through the drudgery
is what you're saying with respect to
yeah absolutely
Daniel I'd love to send you a copy of
our book minimalism live a meaningful
life we talked a lot about values today
and and finding what your values are and
that that book is about just that Ryan
and I when we first started letting go
and pursuing a more meaningful life we
had to identify what our values were
because we didn't know and and if you
don't know what your recipe is for a
more meaningful life then how are you
gonna live it right and so I love this
and you copy that Sean I think you reach
out to Daniel there's sent him the audio
book the book book or the audio book
could appreciate it and for those of you
listen to this we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or tip about schooling or college or
careers including advice for any of our
callers today leave us a voicemail for 0
6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 it's my favorite part of
the show you can also send a a voicemail
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists com
at the end of each show we air our
favorite comments and tips so stay tuned
for that Ryan what time is it
it is time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
yes we do indeed we are on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram at the minimalist
and at TK underscore Coleman at least on
on Twitter I know that for sure
we'll put a link to your Facebook and
Instagram on on the show notes as well
during lightning round this is where
Ryan and I both do our best to each
answer every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now
you're going for the maxims we are and
also we have all of our Maxim's in one
place so you can find them over at
minimal Maxim's com we have people who
set that up as their homepage so there's
over a thousand of our quotes on there
now and so maybe TK you can help us add
to our collection where's our first
question from Ryan all right our first
question is from Tom Tom writes in I'm a
student and I'm struggling with deciding
on whether I should stay where I am or
whether I should change to a different
degree that people refer to as the
better fit for me could you give me some
tips on how to make good life slash
education decisions as a young adult so
so here's the thing we'll give a pithy
answer but we don't have to just be
pithy we can we can ramble on and then
tie it up with a pithy bow right I do
the opposite way I'll say pithy first
and then I ramble on he unpacks it yeah
here's your gift let me open it for you
wait LeBron approach get the
triple-doubles that's first and try to
win the game okay
well my pithy answer is don't confuse
schooling with education and I think
really that too often we'll say well I'm
going to sign up for that course and all
of a sudden via college I'm going to via
osmosis have all of these things in my
brain for years later or I'm gonna sign
up for the Tai Lopez the real estate
course or whatever the hell it is
and all of a sudden just by paying the
money and putting that debt on my credit
card all of a sudden I've attained all
the knowledge knowledge and I doesn't
work that way don't confuse schooling
with education
yeah I would just say the best person to
give you advice on what's best for you
is you it's it's too often that we like
you're the same and we get these social
pressures from parents from friends from
from coworkers whatever telling us what
we should and shouldn't do and it really
it can stunt our our progress in
something and for me I'm trying to think
of like this magic formula like how did
I get confidence she just you know kind
of be vulnerable to put myself out there
to to take a risk on something that
people told me was too risky to take a
risk on like I don't have a magic
formula for that but but I do know that
what did you say earlier the pity thing
you said earlier TK about the only way
man I'm gonna have to go back to the
show notes and look at it no but you're
basically talking about like the only
way you can really you know kind of beat
we were talking about commitment and the
thing that you said about commitment
about really the way to kind of gain
respect is to is to be consistent I'm
doing a very very bad job of the control
of the frame yeah yes so I guess what
I'm trying to say is is that when we use
other people's expectations to to run
our life it's gonna make us it's just
gonna make a strepa daesh's to do
anything on our own and and and there is
there is something that we have to
commit to in ourselves to take a chance
to to go outside of what everyone else
is telling us what to do don't let don't
let others are expectations dictate your
decisions yeah there's something pithy
for you yeah that's good too you know
this is part of me rambling good yeah so
regarding the whole bit about people
saying you should major in this because
it's a better fit for you I would say
the only way to know what a better fit
is is to try it on if I hand you a pair
of shoes and say this is the best fit
for you I might be right I might be
wrong how do you know not by blind faith
not by self-confidence but by conducting
a simple experiment put on the shoes and
you will know with certainty if it's the
right fit for you so
and before you change your major or do
anything dramatic before you place faith
in what other people say before you
dismiss them try it out pull up some
articles on the topic if it's philosophy
get a philosophy book listen to some
philosophy podcasts and then pay
attention how you feel does it bore the
hell out of you
they were wrong it's not the best fit
for you if it makes you say I want more
then conduct some further experiments
try it on for size keep it simple
well that's question all right Josh will
hook one thing I struggle with working
at a university is that there are so
many meetings and administrative tasks
that take me away from my research in
writing but not showing up to faculty
meetings or refusing to pitch in on
admin would reflect poor departmental
citizenship well Maya the answer here is
too often we confound talking about work
with meaningful work I remember back in
the corporate world we had meeting
Monday's I had nine hours of meetings on
Monday we crammed is I had I had the pre
meeting meeting for the first meeting
which was actually the second meeting of
the day and and then from there there
I had a marketing meeting a
merchandising meet like we just filled
back to back-to-back meetings and we had
meetings about meetings about meetings
and after a while you just sorta have to
step back and say okay this is part of
what I'm required to do right now I
couldn't miss those meetings but only if
I could prove that the value I'm
providing is so much greater than
attending those meetings but it has to
be so much better because they put such
an emphasis they put a huge value on
going to those meetings and even though
they weren't valuable we often confuse
valuable with value the values of the
corporation were that you needed to
conform to these meetings now of course
for me it was like okay I'll spend the
other six days a week because there are
seven days in a week I'm gonna work all
seven I'll spend the other six days
doing something that's going to add as
much value as possible but I know I have
to it's easier for me to conform and so
the question that I think Joshua will
hook it has to ask himself here is is it
more valuable for you to conform or
can you provide enough value that you
don't have to conform yeah my short
answer is if you find a job you love
you'll work your ass off to keep that
job so the question is Joshua how much
do you love this job I mean there are
there are obvious administrative things
that the people in the ivory tower are
gonna set up and make you do the
question is is do you still love your
job if I loved managing people I really
loved helping people move from getting
fired to becoming employee of the month
I really loved helping that that person
who really wanted to get that promotion
and showing them the steps and in order
to get a promotion I really enjoyed that
that that level of interaction I had
with people helping them develop their
career in some way that was like 5% of
my job I mean the other 95% it was
filled with meeting Mondays and and you
know a lot of other stuff that I wasn't
willing to put up with so it wasn't a
job that I absolutely loved Joshua if
you absolutely loved your job but you
got these admin things happening like
yeah sometimes you got to do stuff you
don't want to do Josh and I still have
to pay taxes we still have to do a lot
of things that come along with being the
minimalists that are administrative
things that yeah I look at them
sometimes and I'm like what the hell are
we doing but at the whole list of those
things I have to do today I think I can
outsource some of these things but they
won't get done the same way that I want
to do so am I willing to what what's the
decision I have to make right dude if I
outsource it and realize like okay it's
not gonna get done to the level that I
want it to be done I can also have
everything like sometimes I don't want
to write but I'm not gonna outsource my
own writing to other people right and so
I think it's important to yeah make that
decision yo are you willing to Drudge
through that drudgery yeah all right so
I'm gonna adopt an entrepreneurial
approach here because there's there's
learning to accept the things about our
work that we don't like which is just
part of being in a dough but then
there's also giving ourselves the
opportunity to see if we can negotiate
you know our possibilities and and that
that's always something we should at
least give a fair shot at Zig Ziglar
says the best way to get what you want
is to help somebody else get what they
want
your power to negotiate comes from your
ability to figure out why things matter
to other people and then to take your
own self interest and present it to them
in a way
as if it's a segue that leads to theirs
so the first thing I would do is I would
say what is my attendance at these
meetings signal okay and what value does
my presence at these meetings create
don't assume that it's arbitrary don't
assume that you're required to be here
just because someone's trying to ruin
your life there's something that
somebody is getting out of your
attendance at these meetings that's
valuable to them you've got to find out
what that is and make sure your
understanding is really precise then try
to figure out a way that you can amplify
that value by not being at the meeting
but doing something else instead this is
an example that doesn't perfectly apply
because I don't work at a university but
I have a meeting I had a meeting this
morning with my CEO that started at the
same time as this podcast and with great
confidence I said to him I need to
cancel our meeting because I'm going to
be going on the minimalist podcast and
we're gonna talk about a variety of
things one of those things will be
practice and he predictably said cool
why because I know what my CEO wants and
I know what the purpose of the meeting
is the purpose of the meeting is for us
to discuss ways that I can do my job
better in ways that we can grow and
promote praxis me being here is actually
something that allows me to do that more
effectively than being at that meeting
yes the circumstances are unique to what
I do but that but that fundamental
principle is the same everywhere I think
that's right and we got a bunch of a
bunch more questions here unfortunately
that wasn't know around no no it's
perfect that's good we got we got a
bunch more questions here and here's the
thing I was gonna pick one more bonus
question we had two really good ones the
new TK was gonna be here so well we have
two of them here one is from Frehley do
you have any tips to help people in
their 30s and 40s find what they want to
truly do with their time in order to
earn a living and the other one is from
Chris I find the field of education to
be frustrating and broken you have any
advice for teachers considering to leave
their profession so if you want to
listen to our answers to those two
questions you can tune in to this week's
PostScript each week we published a
PostScript episode over on the
minimalists private podcast the Minerals
private podcast is just for our
patreon supporters that's that's why
it's private so if you want to support
our show and help keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimus private
podcast feed includes our monthly ask
the minimalists anything episodes
unreleased recordings from our live
events and the entire back catalog of
past private episodes and once you
become a supporter you'll receive a
personal link to our private feed so
that it plays in your regular podcast
app right next to the podcast that
you're listening to right now and as a
patreon supporter you also receive
access to our monthly live stream videos
as well as first access to tickets to
all of our live events before those
tickets are available to the general
public find all the details and good
stuff over at the minimalists comm slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode one of the
practical tips for people in the 30s 40s
or even in their 50s that are trying to
figure out what to do with their time
they're not living sure I think this is
as much of a problem for people in the
30s and 40s as people in their early 20s
it's just that by the time we get to our
30s and 40s we get a little bit better
at giving up or rationalizing the
choices we've made or or just getting
comfortable or doing things like saying
I'm just gonna focus on on the kids and
giving them the opportunity and I'll
live out my dreams through them but this
is a common thing so number one don't
feel guilty about it
don't feel ashamed of it most people in
their 30s and 40s don't know how to
answer this question second thing I
would say is start small instead of
putting pressure on yourself to find out
what you feel called to do overnight
instead of putting pressure on yourself
to figure out a way to make money you
know in the next six months just start
by asking yourself what are some things
you're interested in
do the Alan Watts exercise about you
know what would you do if money were no
object are there any problems that you
enjoy solving are there any forms of
value that you enjoy creating are there
any people that you enjoy working with
before you think about how to make money
think about what it is you want to do to
create value the second thought is if
the third thing is start experiment
with the little ways alright and we're
back and if you want to hear that full
conversation you can become a patron
over at the minimalists comm okay now
it's time for our added value portion of
the show all right well since since we
have TK here on the podcast I do want to
talk about a couple things one is you
have a podcast called office hours it's
with Isaac and you you you have finished
the first season wins the second season
coming up now is the perfect time by the
way we'll put a link to it in the show
notes but it's just off office hours if
you listen on overcast sore or Apple or
wherever you can just type in office
hours you can find it over there the
first season that now is a great time to
go back and binge the first season if
you have a if you need career advice
they they certainly answer a lot of
great questions about about careers and
and unlike us they keep it fairly
minimal it's succinct you guys do a
great job you answer a few questions per
episode and and I appreciate what y'all
do over there so when season two
starting up
yes so we will actually be premiering
season two live at fee Cohn fee is the
foundation for economic education you
can check out their site at feed org
next month we'll be we'll be doing a
live episode of office hours and that
will be the launch of season two and in
meantime get caught up on season 1 yeah
you can go back and take a listen find
the ones the find the questions in there
that piqued your interest and also you
have another podcast which I have not
listened to so I need to know more about
it small business edge what's that about
small business edge it is a podcast
sponsored by ceteris and with this
podcast we focus on franchise owners and
the everyday lifestyle of CEOs you know
lots of people are familiar with the
titles that correlate with running a
business but most people don't have an
idea of what the day-to-day life is like
if you're a CEO of a franchise or you
know you're the owner of a franchise
rather like what do you do what is what
is an average Tuesday look like we
talked about those kinds of things and
we also talked about the sorts of
difficulties they faced as they
transition from you know having a career
you owning a franchise what what
influenced their decisions what sorts of
things they wish they knew and what are
some of the you know that what some of
the advice they give to other people who
are just starting out got you so uh one
other place to go that I recommend for a
TK : we already recommended the talk
that he gave we'll put a link to that in
the show notes but I want to put a link
to his blog which you can find over at
ek Coleman calm but specifically this
article was called a quick question
about that brilliant idea you have and
I'll just read the first paragraph here
but I'll let you all read the whole
thing because it perfectly sums up the
way I feel about ideas what's so good
about it if you're not acting on it this
is the this is not only a question for
artists entrepreneurs and other people
who identify themselves as doers it's
also for philosophers thinkers
visionaries and self proclaimed idea
guys if you truly find a concept to be
fascinating why not create space in your
life to play with it to experiment with
it to see where it takes you when you
combine it with a little innovation so
let me let me let me ask you this I have
people come up to me that will be like a
book tour or something and it's one of
the things that drives me crazy they're
doing a book signing at the end we're
dishing out hugs to everyone and they're
like hey I've got a really great idea
for a book can you write it for me and
I'm like do you I have a lot of great
ideas most of which I'm not acting on I
don't want to act on your idea because
your idea is worth nothing
it is truly worth nothing unless you're
willing to do something about mmm is
that fair yeah Macbeth's really where
the rest of this article goes and we'll
put a link to it in the show notes but
man I know that we we get these great
ideas we get excited about something but
that excitement is worth nothing unless
you're willing to actually put in the
work to Drudge through the drudgery and
and realize like oh wow
there will be this wasn't a Seth Godin
called the dip right though there'll be
this this this period in time where you
actually feel like oh like this isn't
working out before it does work out and
and the only way you're gonna know is
like well you put the shoe analogy you
got to be a willing to try that idea on
and see if that idea fits absolute
there are a lot of frustrated people in
the world who feel like I'm an ideas guy
I'm really creative and nobody listens
to me nobody takes me seriously and and
there's a very important distinction
that a lot of people who fall into that
category miss out on and it's the
distinction between adding to someone
else's job description versus creating
my own role right and what most people
mistake for having an idea amounts to
nothing more than creating extra work
for somebody else and you shouldn't
expect your CEO or your supervisor to
get excited about your ideas if all that
really means is hey I found some more
work for you to do amiss your already
busy life
no like people respect ideas when you
show a willingness to have some skin in
the game when you show a willingness to
bet on it not when you say hey here's a
book you ought to write but here's an
idea I believe in so much that I took
the time to write the book even though I
knew it was possible that nobody would
even read it even though I knew it was
possible that I was taking the risk of
wasting my time when people see you do
that they respect you they know that you
take that idea seriously and it raises
the probability that they'll actually
engage it I talked about this am i you
know dreams don't come true decisions do
talk that people don't care about your
idea they care about the momentum that's
what they invest in you never see a job
like posting online for we're trying to
hire an idea guy just run out of ideas
and our company needs someone to come in
and give us more work does any
corporation have that position really I
mean it just doesn't happen because the
the ideas aren't worth anything unless
you're willing to to go through the
execution so those are two things that
have added value to my life your
podcasts office hours I definitely
recommend that
check out TK Coleman's blog subscribed
to that and he'll every time he writes a
blog post it will show up right in in
your inbox and also one more thing if
you want to further the discussion on
education the the guy where I first
found you Steven Patterson he has a
recent episode on his podcast which is
called Patterson and pursuit episode 85
it's called college isn't for education
and he interviewed a guy named dr. Bryan
Caplan author of a book called the case
against education which
some irony in there the doctor wrote the
book but also maybe he's the person
who's best suited to write the book as
well he's gone through all the he's
reached level theta seven in the
education process and and learned that
maybe and by the way he is more well
Patterson is is rather dogmatic that's
not the right word but he's he's he's on
one side of the equation he's he's anti
he's rather anti college but the guy who
wrote this book Dr Kaplan isn't
necessarily the he talks about some of
the reasons that you should go to
college and what why it makes sense
since the the stats behind it as well
and so it's a more nuanced approach than
you might think given the the title
college isn't for education can i sauce
into sense yeah of course sent number
one isaac Morehouse also interviewed
Bryan Caplan on his podcast as well and
I think that one's particularly
interesting to listen to because
obviously Isaac Morehouse my colleague
is the founder of an alternative to
college right so he challenges him
questions him and converses with him and
in in a unique way I think you'll enjoy
listening to that I'll check it out yeah
set number two is Brian Kaplan offers an
interesting thought experiment he says
consider what happens whenever there's
something like a snow day or something
happens where you know a professor says
this class is canceled what do students
do they all celebrate they're always
happy right no one's ever angry about
that they're always happy which which is
evidence of the fact that the product
they're paying for it's not information
it's not knowledge it's not learning
colleges the school is the only product
where the customers celebrate when when
it's canceled if you go to the yoga
studio and they said we're closed for
snow date you're gonna be upset right
because you want the yoga what do people
want out of college they want the signal
they want the credential that's going to
signal to the world hey I'm valuable I'm
somebody and once you realize that
that's where the real value is you can
then move to the next question which is
is that the most valuable signal for the
times that we live in given the various
ways that we can showcase our ability to
create value yeah
I was there I was meeting with drew
we're talking about doing music for the
next documentary les is now and we're
pretty much done filming that we have a
few things left and we're working on our
second documentary and drew and and and
Nate they did all the music they formed
a band just for the last documentary
they created the most beautiful music
for it and I went down to Orange County
we were having lunch at this Anaheim
what's it called packing district and I
was there and I walked in the bathroom
and I saw like a guy first I just
thought I was a hipster because we're in
a stethoscope and I'm like is that the
new thing that's in with fashion and
then I realized no he was signaling that
he was you know a like I either are in
residency or whatever like he was
wearing the stethoscope around to show
people like I am a doctor right I'm a
future doctor right right exactly that
that was probably more likely like I'm
an aspiring doctor but I don't know be
like if I walk through it seems like if
I walked around with like a quill pen
and a podcast Sean where were we yet
remember that we were at this bar and
the in the gal was sitting there with
that book what book did she have it was
like this signal like I am a writer and
I'm in this I meant it had to be
Infinite Jest right no no it wasn't I
forget what book it was but it was this
like I'm a writer I'm signifying a I'm
signaling that with this book but they
were in this like really noisy crowded
like college bar again it was just a
signifier to say hey I'm different than
all of you and I'm better than all of
you yeah yeah what's been added by to
your life recently Ryan
oh man you already gave a bunch of
awesome recommendations for TK uh do
I've been listening to this album by
Frank Turner called be more kind well
when I say it's an album it's like you
know how the how the guys are how the
guys and gals are releasing songs these
days like he's got five singles that
he's released on this album uh-huh so
it's more like an EP right now but it's
like a fourth coming out right if
there's like another seven songs that
Frank will release over the period of in
the next ten years I don't even know
like like I don't know what like are
there I don't know what they're doing
these days I know kid
like singles uh-huh but God I think the
album's are dying but sadly it is so
frustrating like he's got five amazing
songs on there yeah and I'm just like
itching to hear the rest but anyway
check out be more combat Frank Turner's
it's a great EP at this point at some
point it will be an album man we first
walked in here Ryan goes can I recommend
a Frank Turner yeah I'm like is this
just some guy you know they use for the
record you guys should be friends with
Frank Turner
all right well check out Frank Turner is
it for me or is it not for me oh no it's
not for you well you you you recommend
are you recommending to me the lead a
wise album the new one yeah that's one
of my favorite albums of the year I
don't know and I told you you would like
it oh my god it's good I knew you would
like that was my that's my
recommendation for the podcast we're
recording tomorrow all right all right
all right new Jack Harlow album that all
right let's see oh right right here
right now it's time for it's time for
right here right now where we talking
about it's going on in the lives of the
minimalist I got a few things going on
here right now else we're settled in LA
finally at least mostly I we like aren't
traveling nearly as much or at all at
this point I'm gonna do a house tour of
my house it's a very ephemeral it's
going to be on Instagram live and so
it'll only be there for 24 hours if you
want to be part of the live session it's
May 11th at 9 a.m. Pacific time or you
can tune in for the 24 hours after that
and you will be able to come into my
house for a little bit asked me a few
questions I'll answer some questions and
we've done this with the last few place
we live we lived in the cabin in Montana
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well you can see a house tour
there or where our two houses when we
were in Montana we did house tours there
and really the purpose of that isn't to
say look at all this stuff that I have
you should have the same brands as me
know as to show you that what I live
with when I live without and what is
appropriate for my life given the the
stage of the life that I'm in right I
have a family a partner and a four year
old soon to be five and here are the
things that are appropriate for our life
right now but also the things that we
live without and we're able to live
without just fine and so it helps you
maybe take a look at my recipe not too
to make the same cake but to figure out
what are the ingredients that you want
to put in your own cake so to speak also
speaking of Education and and not
necessarily schooling I'm teaching so
twice a year I do a writing workshop I
do a longer how to write better class
it's a four week online writing class
but a lot of people have the the time or
they don't want to make the deep dive
commitment that we talked about earlier
so what I do twice a year is I do a live
workshop and allow you to sort of dip
your toe in the water and so that's
coming up June 24th if you want details
on that if you want to learn how to
write better head on over to the
minimalists comm slash workshop it's
called how to write better and it's a I
tweeze out some of my most important
parts of the four-week class it's it's
completely independent so you'll get
value from this you don't have to take
the four-week class it's not some sort
of seminar to get you to sign up for
something else but I want to be able to
help you if you're like you know I
really wanted to start a blog or I want
to write more I've been thinking about
writing a book maybe I can give you a
few recipes a few ingredients for my
recipe that will help move you in the
right direction the minimalists comm
slash workshop that's coming up June
24th also we're doing a video podcast a
video version of this podcast coming
really soon this summer if you want to
subscribe to that head on over to
youtube.com slash the minimalist we're
in our new studio thanks to our patreon
supporters here and so we got the
lighting in here TK you can see this it
it makes you instantly if we turn this
light on it makes you look 73 percent
more handsome immediately yeah and so we
have really good lighting in here we got
the sound panels they they did a really
great job making this studio I mean it's
a it's aggressively simple I think you
would agree with that right and we've
set it up in a way that has worked
really well for us it's a great space I
can't wait to share with you all on the
video podcast and also if you want the
show notes to each and every episode as
well as any new writings from the
minimalist head on over to the
minimalists com put your email address
at the top will never send you spam
because that stuff's gross but will
email you the these show notes every
time we put out a new podcast episode
what else you got for us Ryan I've got
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out
hi Josh and Ryan my name is Emma I am
calling from Liberty North Carolina in
response to your media episode and
specifically in response to the question
about minimized news I have three
podcasts to recommend two are by NPR and
one it's like eating this is explicitly
how I get my news now are almost
explicitly the first podcast is NPR's
hourly News Update it's very small very
bite-size usually about five minutes or
less they update it every hour and using
most podcast apps you can just refresh
it whatever you want to listen to it
typically I listen to it twice a day
during my commute and it's just kind of
a little bite science review of
everything that's been going on in daily
news daily world news the second one is
called up first and it's a little bit
longer usually under 15 minutes and
that's one that NPR releases on weekday
mornings around 6:00 a.m. and that
usually is geared towards people who
only listen to the news once day or
twice a day so it's kind of a roundup of
everything that you might have missed
over the past 24 hours
most of it is politics or world news but
they sometimes pervert entertainment as
well and the third one is called the
world this week it's by CDC typically
about a half an hour and so it's a
little longer and it covers world news
over over the past week in their tagline
it's how the world has changed in the
past 7 days those are the three podcasts
that I used to get most of my News doing
that has allowed me to listen to the
news while I commute which I otherwise
will not be productive during that time
also while I'm doing laundry or cooking
dinner it just allows me to take in the
news at a time when I don't have to
prepare and stare at my phone in order
to do it
hey Josh and Ryan this is Morgan from
Seattle and seem to be fameless Obispo
California
I watched you a documentary in April
2017 and it inspired me immediately over
the following five days I spent 25 hours
going through all my things
I went Pierre les is now stopped in
Seattle and now after 10 months I've
taken a dozen car folds of items to
Goodwill saved a lot of money and freed
up a significant amount of time we're
going to do the Pacific Crest Trail this
year and getting rid of things has
helped to significantly reduce the
stress around moving I've developed a
couple helpful approaches that I think
may also help others so I thought I
might share one I got rid of all my
duplicates unless they were consumables
a donated unused shower gels and lotions
to craft supplies in journals to the
elementary school near my home and
stopped buying trinkets when I visited
new places
ultimately I now only allow for one
duplicate if it's a consumable and no
duplicates if I know it'll take me
months to use up like a journal - for
sentimental items the single most
helpful thing I've done is channel your
phrase our memories are inside of us not
our thing and on top of that I'll allow
myself time my grandpa passed away last
year which allowed me to help my mom go
through my grandparents 50 years worth
of things and exercise my newfound
minimizing skills there were a lot of
memories from my mom so I must say did
an impressively well job with the whole
process but I felt good about being able
to see the thing those things and not
artifacts with my grandparents I did
keep four things from my from their
house a lamp a silver four-leaf clover
an old compact desk and a necklace from
my grandma now as time passes it's
easier to imagine parting with some of
these things as well and they may make
it into my next men's game lastly I have
made these changes once after time over
the last couple months I found myself
naturally focusing on one aspect of my
life
at first it was safe decluttering then
it was finding my
unquote why for not consuming items then
it was working on having good
conversations with friends and family
around the change I was making through
it all I have found it helpful to write
a few relevant minimal Maxim's on index
cards and post them on my desk at work
sometimes I'll also take a picture of
those and make them my phone background
this gives me a daily reminder of what
I'm focusing on and helps me internalize
the approach that I know I want but
sometimes have a hard time staying
consistent within practice hi my name is
Sabrina Carleton I am from Flagstaff
Arizona
I've been listening to and enjoying the
podcast and it's inspiration very much
and I so appreciate it I wanted to leave
a tip for listeners today about both the
mindful acquisition of new clothing as
well as mindfully getting rid of
clothing as someone who does a lot of
outdoor adventure myself including in
the winter time one of the pieces of
clothing that we often struggle with is
our base layers or our long johns and
they are pretty necessary for
adventuring in cold weather whether
you're skiing snowboarding snowshoeing
or just building snowmen in the front
yard base layers can often be pretty
also ill-fitting poorly made the fabrics
are not always very environmentally
sustainable it's certainly something
that I have struggled with plenty of
times I recently came to know about this
clothing company started by a
husband-and-wife team called cargo
clothing and they created their company
to fix this exact problem they focus
exclusively on base layers and they make
all of their things to fit and perform
well all of its may have their
sustainable fabrics and it's made in
Paestum in Colorado it is pricier at
first and some of the cheaper things are
going to find but it is well worth the
price in my opinion but even better than
that they have a mission and a
non-profit arm they call join the flight
and this company allows you to donate
new or gently-used cold-weather outdoor
gear for distribution supporters and
guides in third world countries
Westerners including the founders of
this company in traveling to these
third-world countries to find mountains
have created a demand for guide services
and that's great for the local economy
for these people but
now these people are going to altitudes
and temperatures that they don't have
the proper clothing to be at and that is
putting them in a safety situation so
the founders of cargo clothing will
collect donations of these new or gently
used items that maybe you know someone
gave it to you it's color you like or
just at the fit you plant to your to
your whitening and they'll take them and
they collected and then once or twice a
year they go to the community personally
the founders actually go and hand off
these items to the people in this
community you know that they're getting
into the hands of the right people I
think that's just incredibly incredibly
for how they have seen problems in their
industry and are working to solve it so
if you want to check them out they are
online if you want to check out their
products or join the fight campaign
promo recording comm Corps bro is the
French word for reason it's Sub Zero RB
e au that's really cool people really
interesting company that I thought that
was very might know about all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalist give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and before we leave
here I just want to say TK thank you so
much for being a part of this I found it
to be a really meaningful conversation
I'm grateful you decide to spend this
time with us man this was really fun or
I feel really honored that you guys had
me on it's been great hanging out I
appreciate that so if you all have a
comment or tip or a question for us you
can give us a phone call or you can
leave us a voice memo podcast at the
minimalists comm check out TK Coleman's
work over at TK Coleman comm and if you
leave here with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listen y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus